good morning
okay
this time when i'll call the order the
criminal justice and public safety
committee
representative marston you wish to lead
us in the pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states
at this time we will now
open the public hearing on house bill
this time we recognize representative
abramson
thank you mr chair members of the
committee i'm representative max
abramson representing hampton hampton
falls and seabrook
i'm reintroducing for the third time
what's now house bill 1067 fn
and by the way i want to thank you all
for
uh voting to pass this unanimously twice
before
um the first time it was uh
sent off to the senate
and uh like all the other legislation we
sent their way um they were all all the
bills were tabled and killed
uh because of the coronavirus lockdown
and
the
last time it was sent through it was
vetoed
and i did read the veto message
how however there was a reference to
someone somewhere either in the
department of justice or in one of the
10 county attorney's offices who had an
objection
of some kind and they
whoever that mystery person is has never
contacted me so i'm i'm
i'm not even going to try and speculate
i do want to mention though that there
is
a drafting error in the bill versus what
i requested from legislative services i
ask that this be
this bill be limited to just class a
felonies there was an issue with class b
felonies where i wanted to pass this
bill last year and then come back and
have asked the committee to work on
other class b felony related issues
and of course that didn't happen because
of the veto
so if you look down the only operative
wording in the bill is on page one at
the bottom
part g not withstanding sub paragraphs a
and b for any offense under rsa 631
section one within six years of the
victim's 18th birthday
and then um
legislative services uh
for some reason decided to add in
this this additional language from last
year's bill which isn't supposed to be
there which is for
um class b felonies under rsa 631
section 2.
so it
again this is something i have to come
back with another amendment on but i i
needed to hear from whoever the mystery
person was what their objection was to
the language
i'm told that there's some other
alternative language posted on the
internet somewhere but again no one has
contacted me by email by text message by
phone call i've tried contacting the uh
the governor's office
um and have not actually not heard back
from them in three years so
that's kind of a mystery and i i i feel
like what they're doing is handing this
back to this committee to have this
committee rewrite the bill and if
if you want to take that approach of
course it is
by rules of the house it is now property
of of the criminal justice committee
it's no longer my bill
but i am willing to do the legwork to
rewrite the bill through a committee
amendment
oh so the the reason or the rationale
for the bill is
sometimes people commit felony assault
against a child we have a statute of
limitations for felony assault which is
six years
which makes sense for adults i
absolutely believe in the need for the
statute of limitations the the new
hampshire supreme court argues that why
we need to have a statute of limitations
is to get the prosecutor moving not to
just sit on cases
and to assure that if if you're accused
of of a crime that you have a reasonable
amount of time
to
go back and get witnesses in your favor
the
the reason that we maintain statute of
limitations for most types of crime
other than murder
is
uh
that witnesses for the defense will
forget or they'll move they'll become
inaccessible you won't be able to to do
an out-of-state uh
subpoena and and and bring them in to
testify in your favor so the courts want
the process to kind of move not have
cases just sort of bogged down
the problem with
a felony assault against a child
is sometimes these cases of abuse start
when the child is four or five or six
years old
so if if the victim is six years old
then by the time they're 12 years old
the statute of limitations has already
run out and what we've done with a
felony sexual assault against a child is
we don't we don't start the clock we
don't start the stopwatch until the
victim turns 18
so i felt that we should we should be
using the same type of
logic that
that yes there's still statute of
limitations under this bill
but
that clock shouldn't start until the
victim turns 18 when they're out on
their own and they're not
potentially
either financially dependent on the
abuser or the abuser might still be in a
position of authority over them until
they're 18 years old once someone's 18
then it makes sense that the clock
should run
so that's the rationale for the bill
that's passed unanimously through the
house and senate
multiple times and hopefully whatever
rewording needs to be done
we can get that done before executive
session
representative baberson
thank you for your testimony i will if
you bear with us for about
two two minutes you may be able to see
the
language that you were referencing that
you haven't seen yet
okay
yeah i'll be around this morning
the over under time frame would be about
two minutes i i would say so just bear
with us i'll hang around
i i won't go anywhere
oh did anyone have questions
i was encouraging just just
stay where you're at it should be very
shortly oh i assumed that somebody else
was going to be
speaking also on the bill
if you wish to be excused you may be
excused
i can wait
just to clarify to the members of the
committee there was a letter
that was signed by each county attorney
and it was actually drafted by the
attorney general's office that
reading the letter i believe
it
discussed the intent of the bill which
was formerly hb239
and what it did was provides in that
letter suggested language that would
accomplish the same goal without the
fear of potential unintended
consequences
so the the
suggested language was in that letter
the amendment is word for word that
suggested language
so it wouldn't and i just thought the
prime sponsor
and i apologize for not sending to you
in advance
should have an opportunity to look at at
least review that while he's
here to testify
representatives you can you can have
this copy
and please watch out for those wires
this does kind of look like almost the
exact same wording
do you mind if i
run this down to legislative services
and and take out the
class b felony part so we're just
limited to the class a felony like the
original
you're free to have them make a separate
amendment if you
if you prefer that's that's the right of
any member of the body
okay and i'll make sure that it follows
the uh
i i would suggest that this language was
specifically
word
i don't want to take credit for the
wonderful drafting of it it was it's
literally word for word what was
suggested by
any correspondence from each county
attorney
in new hampshire and the attorney
general but the member's free to proceed
as they wish all right and i'll
i'll be downstairs and i'll uh i'll
return with uh thanks
thank you the member is excused
you
at this time
we'll now close the public hearing on
house bill
at this time we'll we will now open the
executive session on house bill 1067.
representative roy you must be
recognized to make a motion
i wish to move
otp amended and offer an amendment and
offer amendment number
two zero two two
zero one six eight h
is
there does a member wish to second that
motion
that has been seconded by representative
bourdain
representative where you wish to speak
to your motion
i do um
the sponsor's um
intentions notwithstanding
we won't be able to do
much better
getting a language that will
pass
muster than
language given to us by all the county
attorneys and the attorney general
um this is
probably the most vetted language we've
had seen yet so
i think we should just go with it and
moving on
that was well represented
representative rhodes
thank you mr chairman
i basically echo everything that
representative roy has said
and the the concern with not being able
to sign this legislation that
obviously um people were in favor for
was because it was actually going to
hinder if if an assault had taken place
you know after a certain age
we certainly don't want to
want to eliminate anybody because of
their age to be able to
have have their their justice served so
i definitely support the amendment as
written
representative newman
does the amendment that
does the amendment that's going to be
drafted
uh also take out the part that the
representative was concerned about about
class b felonies is that
would that then be gone so it wouldn't
be a problem
the amendment that's been offered was
the one that was recommended by
when i soon say recommended it was
suggested language that and what the
letter was really saying was they
understood the intent of the bill
however as passed by both the both
bodies there was some concern of some
unintended consequences
and they it was suggesting if you if
this is the goal of what is wish to be
accomplished this is the suggested
language to be used
i thought
this is word for word going to match
what was suggested by
in that language i don't i'm not saying
that there any the attorney general's
recommending the legislation but i would
also
be very cautious with changing the
language considering that this
was hb 239 passed on unanimously out of
this committee to last term and last
year
and it got all the way to the finish
line and out of a abundance of caution
that's why i didn't
didn't didn't make it so we're
addressing that issue of the
potential understanding consequences are
addressed by this so i i would be i
wouldn't uh support
any
deviation from that language
i support everything you said i will
support the amendment my question was
about the process i thought i heard in
the testimony
that the representatives mentioned
something about
class b felonies that he was going to
take out and he whatever he was going to
do with that
and i'm just wondering if the amendment
as written now
takes that out or does not take that out
is it does it replace it so it's all
gone or not it's just that it's my
question i don't believe it's
appropriate for me to tell another
member to not get
go ask for an amendment i that's not
fair to anyone so i i don't believe it
takes what's here doesn't take it out
that i believe the witness may have
wanted to do that but i wouldn't support
you thank you i just wanted to know
whether it did or didn't i didn't have i
have a feeling either way i was just
questioning what the amendment replaced
and what it did not replace thank you
very much for the explanation
representative
you're recognized thank you mr chairman
i'm i'm just subbing today but i'm a
little curious um why we're moving this
now until representative abramson comes
back because i think his expectation was
that we weren't going to vote on an
amendment until he had the opportunity
to offer another one
i was just wondering if it wouldn't
if we could just delay this and give him
the courtesy of presenting what he has
in order for an amendment to be
presented to the committee it would have
to be either a member or a sub
be a substitute on the committee and as
the chair excised my discretion i would
not recognize someone to offer an
amendment that wasn't
identical to the language offered as
recommended by the ten county attorneys
and the attorney general's office
because i think because i believe that
this is a bill that we've heard
extensively we've discussed extensively
for
multiple terms and i don't think i'm not
sure anyone opposes the intention of the
bill
so i think it's really the precise
language that we really want to focus on
yeah a follow-up um no i i understand um
my concern was just really a
professional courtesy um so that when he
comes in he's not blindsided that we've
already voted on another amendment
i ca i
well i i understand
what the point that you were making okay
thank you
at this time the matter will now
be put to question of you in support of
adopting
amendment number
oh one six eight
h
please say yay if you were opposed
please say nay
the clerk would not call the roll
vice chairman roy yes
representative welch
representative burt
representative rhodes
yes
representative greene
clark votes yes representative testerman
representative lang
representative pratt
yes
representative marston
representative harriet gathright
representative schultz yes
representative o'hearn
is there a substitute for
representatives
i haven't
no
she's subbing for laura panakas
i have okay wrong all right very good
okay
so it's representative wrong
thank you representative borden bordenay
yes
representative perez
representative newman
yes
representative bolden
no
representative conley yes
representative klein knight
representative bradley
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
17 years one nay
motion passes amendment is adopted
representative roy are you recognized
i would move
hb 1067 to
otp as amended
that has been seconded by representative
conley
does anyone wish to discuss
the motion
i believe um we've discussed it enough
thank you
this time the matter will now be put to
question if you were in sport in support
of the motion of arthur passes amended
police say yay if you were opposed
please say nay the clerk and i'll call
the roll
vice chairman roy
representative burt
representative rhodes yes
representative greene
yes
clerk votes yes representative testament
representative lang
representative pratt
representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright
representative schultz
yes
representative wrong
representative borden a yes
representative perez
yes
representative newman
representative bolden
no
representative conley yes
representative klein knight
representative bradley
chairman abbas chair votes yes
seventeen one three no three not voting
anyone wish to move for consent
would it be a minority report
majority report
at this time we'll now close the public
hearing excuse me we'll now close the
executive session on house bill 1067.
the committee will be in recess to 9.45
you
at this time
i call the committee to order and we
will be opening the public hearing on hp
1577 fn and the chair recognizes
representative abbas to introduce the
bill
thank you mr chairman thank you members
of the criminal justice and public
safety committee
i'm here to introduce house bill 1577
this bill may look very familiar it was
part of senate bill 122 that we
that was championed in this committee by
our friend from keene
and it
did pass but
during the community conference there
were some issues with the
word used was an ominous bill that led
to
the downfall of
this policy so this isn't the entire
portion of senate bill
122 but particularly involving
victims of
human trafficking it captures that that
scope of the bill
and the the primary function of this
legislation was that when someone is
being
a victim of human trafficking that there
will be exempt from certain prosecutions
us particularly
they'll be exempt from
crimes other than violent offenses is
the crux of what this bill would do
i'll defer any questions during the to
when we discuss this during the
executive session
and uh thank you for thank you for
accepting my testimony
the committee now calls joseph ebert new
hampshire state police
good morning members of the committee my
name is joe ebert it is eb ert and i am
a captain with the state police
overseeing our investigative services
bureau which is our detective bureau
uh i've
submitted my pink card today with uh
just informational or really a
comment that we wanted to make on this
in general we are supportive of the bill
we of course don't want to see anybody
who has been the the victim
of
of a crime uh then be charged with an
offense
as a result of it having said that if i
can direct your attention to line six of
the uh of the bill before you where it
speaks about
any individual who at any point in time
was the victim of a severe form of
trafficking in persons
uh offense under 22 usc
and it's the the last portion of that
line where it says whether or not the
offense was prosecuted that we at least
wanted to bring for conversation
that seems like a very difficult bar to
try and attain
if you are looking
as to whether or not
you're going to exempt somebody from a
criminal offense how would you prove or
disprove that
so we wanted to bring that forward as a
point of conversation and i also wanted
to mention that i've spoken with members
of the victims and survivors coalition
and we are more than happy uh and
it seemed like everyone was willing and
receptive to the notion of perhaps
amending the language moving forward
having said that
that is my testimony this morning i'm
more than happy to answer any questions
that you may have
representative newman you're recognized
for a question
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
could i just say
i i read whether or not
an offense was prosecuted is
to paraphrase is
either was or it wasn't so could you
clarify me what for me what how that
might be changed and why it needs to be
changed
uh yes so thank you for the question um
i guess what i the the way i was looking
at this if prosecution is taken on a
given
charge then there is a clear and defined
record or there should be a very clear
and defined record of what took place in
that incident
so uh without that prosecution taking
place
uh
you know perhaps uh there is a record of
it uh perhaps there's not if if you were
to later be talking to somebody who said
well uh 10 years ago i was
a victim of this crime but there's no
documentation of it uh it would be very
hard to either prove or disprove that
notion and that's that's really what we
were getting at um
we're looking at how would you
how would you be able to support or not
support the notion of what was being
said to you if there wasn't an official
proceeding that took place
just for clarification i have a question
so um i just want to reiterate what
you're saying
um so
were we talking about the a defendant
you would be able to
run a triple i and you'd see whether or
not he's probably even if it wasn't
prosecuted but there's no record
anywhere of defendants is that correct
correct and and again i excuse me
victims yeah victims uh uh defendants
there certainly is but with victims um
it is it's not as clear and defined uh
but i just want to make sure that i come
across the committee in the in the right
way and saying that uh in general we're
very supportive of the notion of the
uh of this particular bill we just want
to make sure that we don't um we we
aren't put in a position at a later date
to not be able to approve or disprove a
portion of it
representative newman
thank you and just based upon the
discussion that you had with
representative roy it really and i
wasn't thinking of it this way it really
is trying to
it's hard to prove the veracity of
someone who says they were prosecuted or
they had this crime happen to them is
that
a correct interpretation it is uh thank
you sir uh it is difficult to prove if
somebody says that something happened to
them
uh
if it wasn't prosecuted or if it wasn't
uh investigated it becomes very
difficult if somebody says a period of
time ago this occurred to me
and there's no documentation of that
offense
thank you
there be no further questions thank you
excuse me
i didn't see over there representative
my apologies go ahead
so that uh same statement is uh also in
line b
whether or not the offense is prosecuted
the end of that also
and again
thank you for pointing that out uh
representative that that is uh just
language we would uh we would seek to
clean up uh as
hopefully moves forward too vague okay
thank
you be no further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you very much
the committee now calls tori neville
good morning mr chair and members of the
committee
thank you for the opportunity to testify
today
my name is tori neville and i am a core
member of the new hampshire human
trafficking collaborative task force new
hampshire's human trafficking task force
was first established by new hampshire
senate bill 194 in 2007 to research the
issue in our state and for the past
decade we have evolved to focus as well
on casework training and outreach we are
a group of law enforcement officers
victim service providers attorneys state
agencies and community stakeholders who
respond directly to human trafficking in
the granite state
this multi-disciplinary team is steered
by stakeholders such as the coalition
homeland security new hampshire state
police and the u.s attorney's office
today i am here to provide educational
background on hb 1577 and how it
intersects with anti-human trafficking
work in our state
like many of our community members
before i began my work here on the task
force i had no idea how much this crime
impacts our state i quickly learned
after i joined that the second ever
federally prosecuted case happened right
here in new hampshire last summer i
collaborated with our team when a
trafficker was sentenced to 21 years in
prison for trafficking children and
adults in our state using drugs to
entrap them we are continuously
identifying and interviewing potential
victims who have been connected to us
through local police departments crisis
centers and more avenues
in that spirit i would like to offer
some background relevant to hp 1577.
first you should know that there is a
victim offender duality that exists for
many of the survivors we work with
sometimes drugs are used as a tool of
coercion to suppress victims from
fighting back
sometimes victims are forced by
traffickers to commit crimes such as
theft or selling drugs
sometimes traffickers even use their
victims to recruit further victims and
traditionally these criminal histories
stick with survivors long after they
have managed to escape their traffickers
they label them like scarlet letters
preventing them from moving forward in
society getting a job renting a home and
building new and healthier relationships
the first point i would like to discuss
is that this bill codifies a largely de
facto practice in our state that we do
not criminalize and punish victims
currently defendants can meet the burden
of
proof showing duress by a preponderance
of the evidence moreover if someone is
forced to commit a crime that has
commercial elements that would actually
qualify them as a victim under the state
and federal
definitions of labor trafficking for
example being forced to sell drugs
besides our own practices this bill is
also consistent in spirit with federal
and numerous other state legislation
such as safe harbor laws
these laws prevent minors so any child
under the age of 18 from being
prosecuted for prostitution and directs
juvenile sex trafficking victims to
non-punitive specialized services
here in new hampshire we also use
juvenile
diversion courts across the state and a
growing number of adult adult diversion
courts to provide a place for victims to
heal and exit trafficking situations
without carrying the burden of criminal
histories with them
in october we provided training to these
programs across the state on screening
and referrals for potential victims
ending up in their programs we have
started piloting an anonymous tip and
screening form with manchester drug
court grafton county alternative
sentencing and merrimack county
diversion already leading to several
reliable tips
the legislator also passed legislation
last year that brings all juvenile
defendants with high scores on the
adverse childhood experiences assessment
into these programs we hope this catches
potential victims who are falling
through the cracks giving them more
opportunities to heal and work together
to remove them from these dangerous
situations
in conclusion this bill provides
codified language to what we know to be
best practices and currently seek to
emulate in our state victims should not
be criminalized they should be allowed
to heal and have opportunities and
inclusion in our communities thank you
and i am very happy to take any
questions
representative boarding
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question um the previous testimony uh
indicated that
um
sometimes our
people are not necessarily
prosecuted of the crime is it ever
possible
are sexual
trafficking crimes not prosecuted
because they're not sufficient evidence
unfortunately there are a number of
reasons why
it's very difficult to identify
and prosecute these crimes um just off
the top of my head i can tell you that
we saw hundreds of tips coming in about
trafficking in the state and
only move forward with a handful of
arrests and prosecutions
there's the issue of evidence for when
somebody is in a situation like that
there's also potentially issues of
distrust
where you know victims are told that
they are criminals and that you know the
police aren't going to help them so then
they don't know necessarily that they
can come forward and receive that help
follow-up thank you
so is there any uh evidence or should i
say documentation that
such a crime exists but was not
prosecuted
we do have some very dedicated
law enforcement that looks into all of
the tips that we receive
so i can tell you they're members of
homeland security new hampshire state
police and merrimack county pd at this
point as well as collaboration with
local police departments
so we do have some basic
you know tips that are coming in and
some basic investigation and reports
that are run for any tip that we do
receive
thank you
there being no further questions the
witnesses thanks for her testimony
thank you you're welcome the committee
now calls
lynn charlotte
and a reminder if you have written
testimony please submit it
okay
am i on now you are all right i just
gotta please start over so take two
uh good morning mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is lynn chalet
i'm the executive director of the new
hampshire coalition against domestic and
sexual violence
we are the umbrella organization for the
12 community-based crisis centers that
serve approximately 15 000 victims of
sexual and domestic violence every year
and i am here to speak in support of
house bill 1577
i had planned to share the history of
the bill with you but the sponsor did an
excellent job so you're all up to speed
on the fact that you have seen this
language before
in terms of the current language in
front of you today when we look at the
state's human trafficking laws
specifically rsa 6337
this bill this law has successfully
worked to allow victims of human
trafficking to vacate convictions for
charges that are brought against them as
a direct result of them being trafficked
while also maintaining important
safeguards to make sure that traffickers
can be prosecuted whenever it's possible
as your questions have raised
this bill creates the right balance in
terms of maintaining the legacy of these
two important goals
and the way that it's achieved in this
language is by inserting the language
the word direct to ensure that any
crimes that are sought to be vacated are
directly related to the human
trafficking that someone experienced and
it does a second thing as well which
ensures that the crimes that are vacated
are non-violent crimes
the second thing that's really important
and helpful about this legislation is it
acknowledges the intersectionality that
happens for human trafficking victims
it's consistent with the spirit of our
current law which is to protect victims
from being
prosecuted for something that they
likely had no choice in because that
conduct was so closely linked to the
human trafficking they experienced
however as we said victims who also
commit violent crimes should not receive
blanket immunity for anything they have
ever done and this language
appropriately narrows that
that exemption from prosecution
in the human trafficking field as you
heard from the prior witness we
recognize the victim offender
intersectionality
and what that means is that we as a
society should consider the coercion the
force or the fraud that a victim of
human trafficking may have experienced
when determining whether or not they are
culpable for an offense
under our current law human trafficking
victims can already vacate non-violent
crimes which was a provision that the
coalition supported and held past
so we believe this bill strikes the
right balance for victims of human
trafficking who deserve opportunities to
vacate crimes that were committed as a
result of their being trafficked
i'd also like to respond to captain
ebert's um comment the coalition stands
ready to talk to any partners about any
language that may be needed to be
addressed moving forward i will say that
when you look at that provision it does
provide that there would be a hearing
related to vacating a crime
and that there would have to be a
finding by the court by a preponderance
of the evidence that the underlying
crime was committed as a result of human
trafficking so there are some
protections built into the language now
but the coalition is prepared to work
with the sponsor and other allies to
move this bill forward
i'm happy to take any questions thank
you
there being no questions thank you for
your time very much i'll leave the mic
on yeah
committee now calls melissa brado
good morning
thank you so much for permitting me to
testify my name is melissa bruto i'm an
attorney and an advocate for survivors
of human trafficking
i have been an attorney for 15 years
i helped to write and oversee the
initial implementation of new york's
vacator law in 2010 new york was the
first state in the country to have such
a vacator law
i have also had the honor and
opportunity to train attorneys
throughout new york state and also to
talk to legislators throughout the
country about the creation and
implementation of their vacator laws
so i have a pretty significant amount of
experience in
overseeing
the creation of these laws and also the
implementation on the ground from an
attorney a practitioner standpoint
we were able to pass an expansion of our
vacator act in just in last year in 2021
in new york that permitted expansion to
vacate crimes um committed as a result
of being trafficked both for people that
are forced into sex related labor and
also
non-sexual labor so we we also saw an
expansion of our vacator and we're very
proud of that because we truly believe
that survivors of human trafficking
need a fresh start
in terms of the
comment related to captain ebert i would
just like to note as somebody that has
really been on the ground for over 10
years in both practicing these cases and
and you know training other attorneys to
litigate these cases that i have never
seen that
point being raised in any state that
i've worked in and it's never been an
issue there are
a myriad ways that somebody can prove
that they are a victim of human
trafficking in fact
if you look at section d
the petitioner shall not be required to
provide any official documentation
because as as previously stated by other
advocates that can be really difficult
and very very few cases are actually
prosecuted
incredibly few i want to just make that
very clear
however
there are
many many ways in fact eight are listed
here ways that people can prove that
they are in fact a survivor of human
trafficking so you know it
that is fully built into the law so i
just wanted to make that incredibly
clear and that prosecution is is
certainly by no means the
the best way to prove it because they
happen so infrequently and not because
of the fault of of survivors
thank you so much
there being no questions thank you for
your testimony
is there anyone else wishing to speak
who has not signed up to speak
see no one i will close the public
hearing
on hp 1577.
and 11 15
10 30.
the committee will be in recess until 10
30.
again
sure
yes
keep working
uh
yes
foreign
keen
and then
yes
representative conley yes
representative klein knight
yes representative bradley
representative abbas
chair votes yes
to nothing
one not voting
motion passes
i'd like to make a motion to put on the
consent
some some moves
will you be drafting the majority report
it'd be an honor thank you
and thank you again for your efforts
with this and i'll just say for the
record if i'd known i had the awareness
of the time i would have definitely
asked you to co-sponsor this with me and
i apologize for not doing that
that's okay thank you chairman all that
matters is that this passes for the
people
agreed
this time we will now close the
executive session on
house bill 1577.
at this time we will now open the public
hearing
on house bill 1340 relative to the
definition of domestic violence in
relative to criminal convictions for
domestic violence
abramson you're recognized to introduce
your bill
thank you mr chair members of the
committee i am representative max
abramson here again um for house bill
1340 uh yesterday
relative to the definition of domestic
violence and trying to make the
state definition of domestic violence
match the federal definition
i did speak with people from the uh
department of safety yesterday and we
agreed that there were still a lot of
issues that had to be worked through
um and so we're we're asking you to uh
hold on to this for interim study um but
it is it is your bill now you're welcome
to to to do what you choose that there
were two main motivations for the bill
and then there's also a because it opens
up a can of worms it did create a
complication
um
the
uh complication
from some members of the the committee
is that they wanted to maintain
the ability of someone to get a
uh domestic violence restraining order
against someone so that that was a
complication that that isn't solved by
the bill
and
um
so we felt that uh the bill needed to be
held on to to get additional work i'd
hoped to get a committee amendment in by
today but we haven't had enough time to
work out all the details the
first problem addressed by the bill
um was a few months ago the gun line was
kind of overloaded every time there's a
new uh president elected whether they're
republican or democrat
there's been a huge surge a huge flurry
of new gun purchases
and one of the problems that exists is
when we have a different definition for
domestic violence that it forces the gun
line
because of uh federal background check
rules
um our our state gun line our state
police have to contact uh the courts
and um look at the specific disposition
of every single
prior restraining order or prior
domestic violence case to see if it
might
prevent somebody from buying a firearm
and that's because the definition is
different
the other problem is because we use a
much much broader definition for
domestic violence it's possible for two
family members or two siblings to to get
into a fight and it can turn into a
domestic violence case whereas it
wouldn't in most other states
um so we're we're trying to essentially
have one bill that will will kind of fix
everything without taking away your your
an individual's ability to to
uh request a uh a restraining order
against someone if if they feel that
there's a still a violent situation
going on
so for that reason and because the bill
is going to need more time and it's
going to need to be reopened i'm asking
that the they'll be referred for interim
study
and that's all i have on 1340.
yeah thank you mr chair
uh representative abrams a question
you're recommending interim study
why not
ito
because interim study and itl are
probably going to have the same outcome
uh refer firm term study well
we agreed that the bill opens up a lot
of issues itl
usually provides some kind of hint or
indication that there's nothing
worthwhile in a bill
to be observed or dealt with
we refer bills for interim study on the
commerce committee
because we feel that there's there's
something worth looking at but that we
want the sponsor
or sponsors to come back next year with
a different bill that might try to solve
a problem differently
most of the bills that are coming into
commerce right now are getting referred
for interim study because there's some
there's some value there there's there's
something worth looking at
um but it's going to need something
structurally very different for next
year's bill
thank you
and of course you want to get uh input
from members of the committee before
actually reintroducing another bill
representative boardney
thank you mr chairman thank you for
answering my question um i'm not i'm not
too happy with the idea of interim study
uh how long would it take you to
redraft the bill to your liking uh well
definitely more time than you know
between now and executive uh
sessions so it's interim studies for
reintroducing a bill next year so that's
that would give us another year to work
on the details
thank you
representative the chairman inquire if
there were to be a redraft i'm just i
understand it's not complete but can you
explain perhaps what the spirit of that
would look like
uh that's to deal with for me that's the
to deal with the future problem of you
know you get another you get another
president or even another governor and
there's a huge flurry of gun sales and
that tends to overload the gun line
um so that's a that's a future problem
um and the
the other the other problem uh which may
require a separate bill which is that uh
you could have cases where you just have
family members or people living together
and they get into a fight
a physical fight and
what would normally be prosecuted is
simple assault it gets
viewed as a domestic violence case
i don't think that that was the intent
to have two brothers fighting each other
and both of them end up with felony
convictions or both of them end up
getting into getting domestic violence
convictions where they they wouldn't in
that particular case in most other
states
so by understanding it correctly your
concerns concern is that the two
siblings
were to get into an altercation each of
them could be charged with
domestic
violence is that
correct or even just being a domestic
violence case it can create problems for
the for the for the gun line
klein knight
um thank you so much chair
um if you could clarify you're more
concerned with holding up the gun line
than you are with protecting domestic
survivors from abuse we're not we don't
we're not supposed to debate the witness
and okay that's that's a separate i have
an actual question
uh
on line four it says physical force
and five it says deadly weapon are you
concerned
that
you have narrowed the definition
to domestic
violence to just physical
what page was that
page one line four or part four
line four and five
um
some of those right now with or without
the bill would would
would be a felony so criminal
threatening is usually a felony if you
threaten someone with an actual deadly
weapon
but domestic violence laws usually just
automatically elevate cases to felonies
just by virtue of being a domestic
violence case
in other words we're we're opening up a
whole can of worms
by
introducing this bill it it
and once you start opening things up
um
then there's a lot of work that needs to
be got into i knew that when i
introduced this bill it was opening up a
can of worms but i'd hoped that i would
have time to work with the department of
safety to go over all those issues first
and we spoke and agreed that just
referring this for interim study and
letting the committee go over those
issues open up those issues right now
before bringing in a bill next year
would be the appropriate approach
thank you the witness is excused
the committee now calls richard head
new hampshire judicial branch
morning mr chair members of the
committee my name is richard head i'm
the government affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch
we had two
points that we wanted to bring up for
today one is that there is a
domestic violence task force that the
chief justice has
has put together put it together in
december those meetings were ongoing
the task force is anticipated to come up
with recommendations on legislation
as a result of their meetings today for
example is a public hearing they're
going to be taking public input this
afternoon
and the full expectation is that coming
out of that
task force we're going to see
recommendations on legislation that we
would expect would be part of some bills
coming up next session
um so this bill if nothing else seems
premature before we can bring together
that that kind of evidence and the
testimony that's being developed in that
in that context
so for example in the in the task force
that's meeting we have on it judges
county attorneys
service providers legal assistant
assistants victim witness advocates
coalition
criminal defense attorneys members from
dove casa private attorneys it's a
fairly broad spectrum of individuals
involved in that task force
and they are doing a fairly deep dive
into a wide variety of issues
so at this stage we would suggest that
putting together a single bill relative
to the definition of domestic violence
that would
uh narrow the definition as compared to
what what we have today without having
heard the input from the task force
may make this bill premature may also
lead to confusion because if a bill like
this
and now i understand it would be put
into interim study
but
once you start creating you know a
series of movements in the definition of
domestic violence you create a
significant risk of confusion
both in the public both in and in terms
of how
these statutes are being
interpreted over time
and then finally you know there are
a wide there are a number of statutes
that use the term abuse and domestic
violence and as those terms diverge you
create additional opportunities for
confusion
where you know the the
how you would start to interpret those
two words or those two phrases
in different statutory contexts can
uh lead to you know some significant
unintended consequences without really
evaluating all of the statutes that use
these terms how are they uh how are they
used how they've been defined by the
courts and it just seems like a
process that's best suited for the task
force to really do the deep dive so with
that i'd be happy to answer any
questions
that the committee may have thank you
representative roy
thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my question um i
speaking for myself i agree with you
this is uh this needs a lot of work than
study
um your this task force you spoke are
there any legislative members on this
task force um
i do not
hold on
i do not believe so but i'm just double
checking uh my list
does not have any legislative members
follow-up
you recognize for a follow-up is the
purpose of this task force to recommend
legislation
the purpose of the task force is to
um evaluate they have a
a number of questions and it's on the
court's website is a sort of list of the
charge that that they have i mean you
may hear from some of the other speakers
as to some of the specifics but the um
some of them some of those do involve
legislative changes if
ultimately those are needed in order to
as part of their evaluation of those
issues yes
okay thank you
if the chair may inquire with the
question
so
there's
would changing the definition of
domestic violence uh disrupt do you
believe that that would disrupt the
efforts of the task force i think it
would disrupt the efforts of the task
force and uh create some significant
potential confusion
among advocates among those in the
public who may be impacted by domestic
violence and create a time in which the
courts are now interpreting domestic
violence differently over a period of
short windows of time if next year were
to change again all of which could could
lead to uh potential damage and harm
thank you for taking my question if i
can also inquire
will this task force put together a
report would you be able to have that
report forwarded to the committee
absolutely i can certainly ask anyway
i'm not a member of the task force but
um can certainly uh make sure
certainly any any report that they issue
is going to be
made public and distributed but
certainly i assume the legislative body
would get a copy
thank you
representative newman
not knowing the how the your commit your
task force is set up and and however
they get members or how they get that
input
um do you do you know of any way that
that that task force might be able to
get as they consider these things get
input from legislators as opposed to
writing a report and then the
legislators
crafting legislation based on the report
which
seem to be much more timely i mean
certainly today there is an opportunity
for anybody to provide input
there is uh there are
they do have a way of
written testimony to be submitted to
them at any time
the task force was created by the chief
justice following incident that occurred
at the end of last year
an internal report was issued and that's
available on our website relative to
that incident and then there seemed to
be in in light of circumstances a need
to do a much more in-depth evaluation of
of domestic violence issues generally
so this task force was created by the by
the chief justice in order to really do
that deep dive
currently doesn't have sort of a
separate mechanism for
for legislators but i can certainly talk
to them about about that
representative newman recognized for a
follow-up
thank you mr chair so
a legislator of legislators that have
proposed legislation like for being to
be considered as a bill could submit
that information to the task force for
them to consider it so that they would
understand maybe the direction that
certainly any legislation wanted to go
absolutely thank you and and uh
certainly anything could be submitted
and any anybody who has
uh thoughts or input
certainly can and if you go to the the
supreme court website um the task force
does have its own
its own website
if you drop down through the through the
links on the on the supreme court
website through committees
representative klein knight you're
recognized um thank you chair and um
thank you so much to the witness um
basically answering all the questions
that i still had the same questions as
my colleagues um just to narrow the
scope
um
one last question basically would you be
willing
even though you're taking a broad look
at all domestic violence and how it
relates to the current laws would you be
willing to take a look at this language
during your meetings so to be clear i'm
not on the task force um i'm not a
member of it anybody who has uh
suggestions or input i think would be
uh it would be filed through the through
the committee the the chair of the
committee uh as justice hans marconi
and
but i think going through the through
the portal that's on the uh through the
committee website is
is the better way of approaching it i
certainly am not a member of the
committee
represent clyde knight you recognize for
a follow-up thank you um
i this is pertains to um members that
i've previously spoken to
um
is anybody aware that there's actually a
public hearing for that very task force
at 1 pm today that they can attend and
bring forth this language
i'm sorry i misunderstood the question i
think
i i just want to notify everybody just
because this is an important topic
we at the conclusion of of the witnesses
testifying
i'll recognize you to make a
statement
thank you
representative boardner you recognized
for a question
thank you mr chairman uh thank you for
the testimony um can you reiterate to
what the name of this task force is
uh it is called the domestic violence
task force
all right thank you
i'm happy to
circulate a link to the to the committee
website um to this committee on as soon
as i'm done here
thank you thank you for your testimony
thank you
the committee now calls andrew
libernor
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for uh hearing my
testimony this morning my name is andrew
libernois i am the belknap county
attorney
and i'm here in opposition to this bill
i think this is a very bad bill
i should say before i begin that i have
had an opportunity yesterday i sent an
email around to all of the other
uh nine county attorneys in the state
and uh i heard back from seven of them
of the seven i heard back from there all
are opposed to this bill
the other two i didn't hear back from
but so seven out of the nine
so seven out of the ten of us
are opposed to this bill i think this
i've submitted written testimony in
opposition to this bill and so i will
not go through my entire written
testimony at this point i do want to
highlight a few points however of
specific concern that i have
one is
what this bill will do in terms of
a person's criminal record and what is
recorded on their criminal record
as it stands now
let's say you have a situation where
somebody
engages in an assault on someone where
there is a serious bodily injury
and if it's a stranger that gets
recorded on a person's criminal record
as simply second-degree assault
but if it is a boyfriend and girlfriend
who are in an intimate relationship
that gets recorded on that person's
criminal record as second-degree assault
domestic
violence if this bill were to pass that
would no longer be the case
because this defines
uh domestic violence to only be
misdemeanors oddly enough
then that second-degree assault charge
would not be listed on someone's
criminal record as i read this bill
as domestic violence would simply be
simple assault
this is very problematic because as a
prosecutor it's important to me
to be able to look at a person's
criminal record
and see whether there's a history of
domestic violence on that person's
criminal record that's important
information
for me to be able to decide about asking
for
bail
preventative detention what sort of
sentence i'm going to ask for
whether to ask for a batterer's
intervention or some other sort of anger
management program for this person if
they're convicted so that's important
information that is now going to be lost
if this bill were to pass the other
problem with this bill is i think it
makes it very confusing in certain cases
as to whether the police can make a
warrantless arrest
so currently
in order for the police to be able to
make a warrantless arrest
for a crime that was not com for a
misdemeanor that was not committed in
their presence
it has to be
abuse
and a domestic violence relationship but
because this
bill
would detach
the definition of abuse from the
definition of domestic violence there
will be cases
where a crime is abuse but it is not
domestic violence and the police will
not be able to make a warrantless arrest
so for example again a boyfriend and
girlfriend who are in a domestic
relationship but don't live together
in an assault happens in that case the
police will not be able to make that
warrantless arrest within 12 hours
that's a bad development
so in some
i think this is a bad bill i think it
causes a lot of confusion in the law
in an area where there's already some
confusion in the domestic violence laws
this makes it worse
not better
and i think it's bad for victims it's
bad for the criminal justice system so i
ask you to please vote in expedient to
legislate
thank you
oh and i'll take any questions i
apologize
thank you thank you for your testimony
the committee now calls chief dave
goldstein new hampshire chief of police
association
morning mr chairman members of the
committee
for the record my name is david
goldstein and i'm the police chief in
the city of franklin
i've been a police officer for more than
42 years
and for 23 of those 42 years i was a
member of the new hampshire state police
for the last 18 years i've been a police
chief in two municipalities
during my tenure as a member of the new
hampshire state police i was assigned to
the major crime unit for more than a
dozen years
during that time i was involved with the
investigations of over 100 homicides
now the reason that i can say was
involved in that many homicides as
opposed to the actual
investigations was because my primary
responsibility in those days was crime
scene
and we had a fledgling crime scene unit
that went from
uh case to case to case if you will so
we actually um
we actually worked more cases than most
of the detectives in the unit
in concert with the national average at
least 50 percent of those murders were
domestic violence related
the oldest domestic violence victim in
one of my cases was a woman in her 80s
and the youngest was a girl who was 10
weeks old
the latter was a domestic mass murder
here in concord in 1991.
and if i'm not mistaken the only
domestic mass murder that we've had in
our state's history at least for the
past 40-plus years that i've been on the
job
james colbert murdered his year old wife
and his three daughters two and a half
years old one and a half years old and
10 weeks old
and
excuse me
i'm here today to testify in opposition
to hb 1340 for the new hampshire
association of chiefs of police i serve
as the chair of the legislative
committee for the chiefs
your chiefs are deeply committed to
ensuring the safety of all victims of
domestic and sexual violence and we are
just as dedicated to our
responsibilities to investigate such
offenses
this legislation will make it harder for
law enforcement to do our jobs and only
create confusion when it comes to
investigating crimes of domestic
violence and making appropriate arrests
i'm going to go a little bit off script
here for a moment and share a
war story with you
i started my career with the derry
police department in 1979
and in those days we didn't have half
the statutory issues that we have today
to protect the victims
of domestic violence
one night i was working on patrol and a
young woman was brought into the
hospital who was the victim of domestic
violence
her live-in boyfriend had beaten her to
with an inch of her life
he'd thrown her down a flight of stairs
he kicked her he punched her even hit
her with a suitcase
and i took the report as best i could
because as you can well imagine she was
being treated medically at the time
and i arrested the assailant
a month later to the day
she came back and recanted her statement
now in those days we were too ignorant
to understand the mechanics
of what went on with domestic violence
victims
and since she came back to recant the
statement in front of me she just
committed a misdemeanor in my presence
what's known as an unsworn falsification
i arrested her
i will stand before you or sit before
you as i am right now and tell you how
embarrassed to this day i am that i did
that
but that's the way things were done in
those days let's not go back to those
days let's keep it the way that it is
we believe that the changes the bill
proposed or the changes proposed in this
bill dangerously restrict the ways in
which victims can seek relief that they
need
by way of another example a short time
ago there was a
horrific case in which a woman was shot
by her ex-partner in a murder-suicide
attempt
this occurred only a few weeks after the
woman had been denied a protective order
since then the task force has been
convened to look into
into these issues and we do have a
representation the chiefs do have a
representation on that task force
and we're looking to actually expand the
definition of domestic violence any
efforts to do the opposite should be met
with an immediate ito
thank you and i'm happy to answer any
questions you might have
thank you chief for your testimony
can you now call steve andres
good morning members of the committee my
name is stephen hendris i am an
assistant county attorney
in merrimack county i've been a
prosecutor for over 20 years and i'm
actually on the
domestic violence task force from the
supreme court
attorney halverson the merrimack county
attorney was unable to be here today he
did prepare a letter which he asked me
to read
he writes today i read the i read the
prepared text of testimony
belknap county attorney andrew libernois
will submit on january 21st 2022
concerning house bill 1340. my schedule
does not allow me to be present for the
january 21st public hearing on this
matter however i do want to ensure my
concurrence with the comments of the
county attorney livernois
is on the record with the committee
he writes i urge the committee to vote
house bill 1340 as proposed as
inexpedient to legislate
i agree with those concerns
i agree that house bill 1340 is is a bad
idea
as attorney livernoise points out the
definition of domestic violence would be
limited to misdemeanor level offenses
the bill actually has nine sections
section two talks about first degree
assault
but first degree salt is a felony so you
could never have
domestic violence first degree assault
if you limit the definition of domestic
violence to misdemeanors
the same is true of the third section
which talks about second-degree assault
you could never have
secondary assault domestic violence
because second-degree assault is a
felony
and this definition would limit it to
misdemeanors
the fourth section talks about reckless
conduct which can be charged as either a
misdemeanor or a felony in new hampshire
depending on the facts the case
however the definition talks about
the threatened use of a deadly weapon
if you had the threatened use of a
deadly weapon reckless conduct would be
a felony
and again as we've talked about
you can't have
felony domestic violence because the
definition would limit it only to
misdemeanors
section 5 talks about aggravated felony
sexual assault again that's always a
felony in new hampshire
since the definition of domestic
violence would be limited to
misdemeanors you could not have domestic
violence aggravated felonious sexual
assault
section six talks about felonious sexual
same thing that's always a felony in new
hampshire so you could never have
domestic violence related felonious
sexual assault
section seven talks about sexual assault
which is in fact a misdemeanor
so it would be theoretically possible to
have domestic violence related sexual
assault under this bill
however if you go back to that
definition
and you need an attempted use of
physical force or the threatened use of
a deadly weapon
we would never charge a misdemeanor
sexual assault with physical force of
the threatened use of a deadly weapon
those would become aggravated felonious
sexual assault
so that section
well it would be theoretically possible
in reality you'd probably never have
domestic violence misdemeanor sexual
assault
the eighth section talks about
kidnapping
kidnapping again is always a felony in
new hampshire so you could never have
domestic violence related kidnapping
because domestic violence would have to
be a misdemeanor
the last section stalking section 9
stalking
generally is a misdemeanor in new
hampshire it can be charged as a felony
under certain circumstances
but i have a hard time imagining how you
would have stalking
that had the attempted use of physical
force or the threatened use of a deadly
weapon
without that being charged as
a felony criminal threatening a felony
assault or some other type of felonious
conduct
interestingly
representative abramson indicated that
his concern was siblings
engaging in a fight and that being
recorded as domestic violence
certainly in new hampshire if two
siblings were engaged in a fight they
could be charged with domestic violence
under rsa 631-2b
this bill wouldn't change that
this bill doesn't reference rsa 631 2b
in any way
and wouldn't solve the problem that he's
indicating exists
i don't feel that's a problem
but
that that's
perhaps his opinion
the other comment i would make is that
he indicated most domestic violence
cases are charged as felonies
that hasn't been my experience domestic
violence under 631-2b which is the new
hampshire domestic violence statute
the majority of crimes under that
statute are in fact misdemeanors and are
in fact charged as misdemeanors
be happy to answer any questions if you
have any
you the witness is excused thank you i
just submit
your written testimony excuse me
representative martin you're recognized
for a question
i apologize
thank you mr chairman and and thank you
for your testimony
i'm under the impression you would like
to see us itl this bill
yes
follow-up
that wasn't a question but
you're recognized for a question thank
you
i'm a little bit confused the sponsor
wanted to maybe go to an interim study
and you're talking about an itl
and i understand the two differences
uh
what
are we i'm
we
withdraw
thank you
i got it
the witness is excused
the committee now calls lynn charlotte
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee my name is lin chalet i'm
the executive director of the new
hampshire coalition against domestic and
sexual violence we have prepared
extensive written testimony to provide
to the committee today and since we're
hearing a lot of similar concerns about
this bill i'll abbreviate my comments we
are here in strong opposition to this
bill and do urge you to itl the bill
it does significantly narrow the
definition of domestic violence and
frankly rolls back decades of work in
terms of responding to victims of crime
there are three significant reasons we
encourage you to itl the bill
and the first is how significantly it
narrows the definition of what domestic
violence is an assistant county attorney
andres really demonstrated that clearly
for you
i don't think we can debate the
pervasiveness of the problem of domestic
violence in our state in the last four
years our twelve crisis centers have
served over six thousand child and
adolescent victims nearly fifty thousand
adult domestic and sexual violence
victims they have answered over two
hundred and sixty six thousand hotline
calls and our eleven emergency shelters
have provided over a hundred and sixty
thousand nights of shelter for people
fleeing danger
what we know is that domestic violence
is a pattern of coercive behavior and
new hampshire addressed this fact in
when we passed what we often refer to as
joshua's law identifying the very
specific crime of domestic violence and
you heard from attorney county attorney
libernoy this morning why that is so
important it helps prosecutors in making
really critical decisions in their cases
also under this bill another concern we
have that i don't think folks have
touched on this morning is that for a
charge of domestic violence to occur the
victim would have to provide proof of a
physical threat
by a deadly weapon this completely
ignores decades of research of what we
know about how domestic violence happens
and it doesn't always involve a weapon
and often there are very nuanced ways
that offenders threaten coerce and
terrify victims of this crime
the second reason that this bill is
problematic is that it would limit
access to protective orders in the state
of new hampshire as you've heard from
other witnesses this morning under
current law there is a broad definition
of who may apply for a protective order
a family or household member or a
current or former intimate partner
by narrowing this definition we are
ignoring what really happens in many
domestic violence cases sometimes it is
committed by a sibling sometimes it is
committed by an aunt or an uncle it is
important that those victims have access
to the remedies that exist under new
hampshire law
it's already difficult to get a
protective order if we look at the data
in new hampshire between 2018 and 2019
there were 8 000 petitions filed for
domestic violence protective orders only
38 of those final petitions were granted
if we narrow the definition of who is
eligible we are denying all of those
people access to that remedy
and the third and final reason uh we
echo what chief goldstein presented to
you today
if we remove this uh
definition of domestic violence and we
narrow it so much it will take away from
law enforcement the ability to identify
some of the most risky crimes
in new hampshire right now we use a tool
called the lethality assessment program
it's often referred to as the lap
program
it is a questionnaire that law
enforcement officers use when they
respond to the scene to identify victims
at the highest level of lethality and to
link them immediately to crisis centers
keeping this definition the existing
definition of domestic violence is
imperative to support law enforcement
officers who are responding to the most
lethal cases the ones where victims are
most at risk of being killed
so in conclusion we strongly urge this
committee for all the reasons you've
heard this morning to vote itl on house
bill 1340. thank you and i'm happy to
take questions
representative bourdain
thank you mr chairman thank you for
testimony uh is your coalition
represented on the task force for
against domestic violence thank you for
the question representative yes we are
we have two staff members who are
serving on the task force and i am one
of them thank you
representative bert you're recognized
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony
on the 8 000 cases that were filed uh
could you get
us you know email us
um
you know what
was fun you know approximately you know
what percentage was filed for
x number and this particular situation
and why are and why they were granted
and not granted thank you for your
question representative so the courts
produce data on the protective orders
and you heard from a representative of
the courts this morning
the number of petitions that have been
granted and denied is summarized in the
semi-annual bi-annual i always forget
every two years domestic violence
fatality review report unfortunately we
do not have data though available in new
hampshire on why those orders were
granted or denied we can certainly get
you broken down by court how many were
granted and denied but the reason for
those is not available to any of us
although it's an important conversation
to have
representative burt you recognize for a
follow-up
thank you mr chairman uh it is very
interesting to have um so is there a way
that you could just send me the link
so i could go and study it myself and
maybe research it a little different
because that number really does intrigue
me we can absolutely send you the report
it's available on the department of
justice's website but i'm happy to get
the link to the committee thank you i
appreciate your help
thank you the witness is excused thank
you very much
the committee now calls aaron jacina
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee my name is aaron justina
and i direct the domestic violence
advocacy project at new hampshire legal
assistance
we represent low-income victims and
survivors of domestic violence sexual
assault and stalking in their high
lethality protective order cases as well
as their divorce and parenting cases and
when i refer to high lethality cases
those are the cases where there is
significant risk to the victim that they
will be killed or seriously harmed by
their abuser
i also want to mention that i am a
member of the domestic violence task
force
in 2021 nhla represented 207 victims and
survivors and spent over 9 500 hours
representing victims and survivors in
new hampshire courts statewide i am here
today to testify in opposition of house
bill 1340.
the terms domestic violence and domestic
abuse are often used synonymously and
interchangeably
this bill seeks to amend rsa 173 b1 to
include a new and separate definition of
domestic violence if interpreted
literally new hampshire would then have
a definition for domestic violence and
another definition for abuse
that's one particular outcome if this
bill is passed
another outcome is that this amendment
to the statute is purposely changing the
definition of abuse so that both
domestic violence and abuse should be
used interchangeably if that is this
case the case this bill has far-reaching
negative impacts which will make it
harder for victims to seek and obtain
protection from our courts
under current law victims may seek an
order of domestic violence protection if
one or more of eight particular acts are
committed or attempted to be committed
against them that includes criminal
threatening destruction of property
harassment interference of freedom those
are some examples of the eight
if house bill 1340 were to pass it would
limit the qualifying acts to the use or
attempted use of physical force or the
threatened use of a deadly weapon
therefore those cases where the victim
was not physically assaulted or held at
gunpoint may no longer be eligible for
protection under our law as i've just
mentioned there are crimes which do not
involve
involve physical assault or a weapon but
are no less serious in terms of placing
a victim in fear for their safety and
well-being
passage of h.b hb 1340 takes protections
away from victims it does not enhance
their safety or make it easier for them
to access much needed relief from our
courts
for these reasons nhla respectfully
asked this committee to vote inexpedient
to legislate on house bill 1340.
thank you for your consideration and i'm
happy to take any questions
there being no questions witnesses
excuse thank you for your testimony
thank you so much
representative
perez
we do we you do have a pink card
submitted what i
you
a member is
i suppose more than welcome to testify i
will assure you that if
we will likely have an executive session
today
and i'll be sure to recognize you to
speak
so
i'm just asking with me saying that
would you still wish to
testify
because the other the other concern is
i'm not now
but if you are testifying you're not
supposed to ask questions i don't recall
if you asked any witnesses questions
that's the
so
i don't know the answer to that but
i assure you i will recognize you to
speak during an executive session
this time we can now close the public
hearing
on house bill 1340.
at this time we will now open the public
hearing on
house bill
relative to an unsolicited disclosure of
an intimate image
the committee calls
representative nutting wong
representative the floor is yours
thank you thank you members of the
criminal justice committee um i'm here
thank you for the opportunity to
introduce hb 1388 relative to the
unsolicited disclosure of an intimate
image
this bill would criminalize the
unsolicited disclosure of an intimate
image otherwise known as cyber flashing
um if it were to become law it would
make the unsolicited sending of
genitalia via electronic device between
adults and misdemeanor
the action of sending this these images
is harassment with nearly no recourse
for the people who receive them when i
receive a message or email i expect to
have a conversation not sent graphic
images with no warning
these images are often sent without
prior contact purely to get a response
when i've received one the advice i've
give i'm given is to block the sender
indecent exposure is a similar crime
with often no proof with similar
recourses i'm asking for in this bill
but a cyber flasher can send many more
images at a time and the proof is right
there
i have included two studies done by
yougov in the uk which have not
surprising results almost 20 percent of
women in the study have received these
types of images
62 of them were received by text message
this is a pervasive growing problem that
is only going to get worse as time goes
on unless you put a stop to it now
on the back of my testimony i've also
included
the full law so you can see how it fits
in there
i know before there have been concerns
about um the effects on children that's
already illegal so i just wanted
um to be able to see the larger picture
um with that i conclude my testimony
thank you so much
representative marston you were
recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony representative my
question is this how do we enforce this
law if we make this law
thank you for your question if we were
to place this in law i believe if you
were
the victim would have to report
to the police what happened
thank you representative lang you're
recognized
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question my my question is similar to
represent martians but it has to do with
accidental disclosure right so i
intending to send it to someone who i
have a relationship with but i
accidentally typo the number now i
knowingly transmitted the message but i
went to a person i didn't intended to go
to and that person reports me how was
that dealt with in this law
thank you for your question as i'm not a
lawyer or a police officer i am not
really qualified to answer that question
but um hopefully you would apologize and
hopefully that way to solve the issue
and maybe double check
representative klein knight you're
recognized
thank you chair um thank you
representative for taking my question
um do you believe that um a complaint or
any other line of
formal
um
basically if you go to the police and
complain about anything there should be
a investigation conducted so this would
probably fall under that realm
to solve
all those issues
thank you um i think so yes i imagine
again not a lawyer not a police officer
i imagine you would go to the police say
hey look at what happened and you'd have
the screenshots right there because it's
a text message
and um
yeah that was how to be handled
representative wrong
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
in the bill it states an image does that
include like video images or just
screenshots still images
i'm thinking of a situation where there
may be someone who's on a zoom call or
whatever and then
you know starts displaying some of this
behavior
and it's not i don't know would it be
defined as an image even if it was like
video or
um thank you for your question i believe
so yeah okay thank you
representative bolden
thank you for taking my question
so i'm looking at the um
the area of criminal code that would be
changed by your bill
and it looks like the indecent exposure
law
was put into place
in 1971
i know that that's before the internet
existed
so is it your intent
essentially to
expand the indecent exposure laws that
we already have to include
um flashing that occurs over the
internet is it basically is that your
intent yes thank you that is my intent
thank you
representative
um thank you mr chair um i actually
think that my question has already been
answered i apologize
representative conley
thank you mr chairman thank you uh
representative the question about the
zoom is actually
one that i don't think had come up
during prior testimony on this bill
it sounds like it might be covered but
was that the intent to include that as
well so that all manner of
unwanted exposure in this way would be
covered
um thank you for your question um when
this
when i first submitted this bill back in
um zoom wasn't really that big of a
thing
um so
back then it was not quite um my intent
however since then um
yes
i'm really happy that i would hope that
this includes that as well um actually
we've had an experience where my my
mother's a church group got um zoom
flashed or whatever you call it
um where you know these nice old ladies
doing bible study did
get um
to get hacked and it was um
very disturbing my mother was telling me
about it and i was like wow i have a
bill for the past two years um but yeah
um i do hope that it would cover that
however it would be a new hampshire
thing so it might get a little difficult
there but
representative bert you were recognized
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony
i think i remember this bill um
i'm not i almost think this question was
asked so i'm asking it again if this is
the correct bill what happens if a boy
and a girl are together
they're sending pictures back and forth
and then one of them breaks up with the
other and then the other one goes to the
police like what they're sending me
um how do they deal with that
so that way there's you know not that
backlash of you know i'm gonna make you
pay and this is how i can do it
um
thank you for your question again
consent would have to be determined by
the police officer of the court
um
but i think it's pretty clear in the
bill that the consent does need to be
fair
um whether that's implied or not
i'm digging myself a hole in this
question all right um but yeah
all right thank you
we understand that the witness is not a
police officer
representative bolden
thank you for taking another question
from me
um
and i understand that
there are other areas of law
that determining whether a crime has
occurred depends on the ability of law
enforcement to determine
consent
do you know of some examples of other
areas of law where
police would have to determine whether
consent
existed before they can begin an
investigation
for example um
sexism
assault at first um
but yeah crimes like that
so maybe like other
yes other
other crimes do
um exist
based upon consent and they seem to
handle them pretty well
thank you
if i may the chairman inquire if i
understand that your testimony correctly
there are certain situations where there
can be human contact that is not illegal
because the contact is
consented to in one way or another yes
thank you
representative klein knight thank you
chair um thank you for taking my
question this is more of um just um
language question real quick on line
six it says uh who is 16 years of age or
older
um would i feel like
uh
we should strike it should be all people
um i'm not i don't know if you're
amenable to a
um amendment
uh well
but i'm unless they're baby pictures i
feel like we might get into trouble here
the back of my testimony i did include
the full law um currently if you're 16
years or younger it's already illegal
um so
if you wanted it to be all the same
then sure but it already is covered
thank you for clarifying that
representative wrong
thank you mr chairman and and thank you
representative this is sort of a
follow-up to my earlier question and to
um
others that have been asked but
in in the um current legislation is the
term image defined
uh thank you for your question i'm
reading it now and i don't think it's uh
especially defined more than
it already would be in the law
all right follow up mr chair you
recognize for a follow-up
do you think it would strengthen this
bill if there was a definition of image
so that it could specify any
not just a still picture but a video
image or a live
in person
[Music]
communication
you know like like a electronic
communication like zoom
um so i appreciate the question i think
the reason why we wrote it the way it is
is just to keep everything kind of the
same so there's not a special law for
adults like
and children so that way the definitions
are similar
um
so
maybe but the reason why it's written
the way it's written is to fit well
with the law affecting minors okay thank
you
representative schultz
i think i am going to ask that question
um thank you mr chair
um
isn't it true that there already are
laws on the books uh involving images
in cases of child uh pornography
um thank you for your question yes and i
belong i believe um they would also be
part of like the revenge porn law which
i believe is one section down from the
current one
representative bolden
thank you for taking what i hope will be
my final question
do i understand correctly um because i'm
looking at again the criminal code that
you gave us the existing law
do i understand correctly that under
current law sending an image
and the word image is
in the existing law
already in use
that's sending an image to someone under
16 is a felony
and there's currently no penalty
for sending an image to someone who's 17
18 or 99
and
do i understand correctly that you're
seeking to make it a misdemeanor to send
an image
a word that's already used in the
current law
to someone 17 or older
uh thank you for your question yes thank
you
thank you for your testimony
the witness is excused
the committee calls lynn charlotte
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee lynn chillette with the
new hampshire coalition against domestic
and sexual violence um we've also
submitted written testimony and your
questions have addressed most of the
issues
we are
happy to be here in support of this bill
and want to thank the sponsor to her
commitment
there was a similar bill introduced last
session and we were able to work with
law enforcement prosecutors the icac
task force and advocates across the
state to come up with this language i
think representative bolden you
summarized effectively
what this bill does it recognizes that
sending these images right now to a
minor under the age of 16 is a felony
and it fills in a loophole in the law
and addresses that it would be a lower
level offense to send them to someone 16
years or older receiving an unsolicited
sexual image is disarming it could be
frightening it could be alarming
and it also is often used by abusers as
part of the grooming process so we
believe that it's appropriate for this
to be an offense but at a lower level
than it would be if the images were sent
to a minor
so i'm happy to take questions i'm also
aware that um assistant county attorney
andrus is still here because i know you
all had a lot of legal questions about
how prosecutors would respond
representative klein knight
um thank you so much chair and thank you
for taking my question and this might um
if you can answer this maybe the um next
speaker can um roughly do you know how
common this is
i don't have any data on that unlike the
earlier questions about data but
certainly in terms of survivors that we
serve at crisis centers we know that
technology is used more and more in
stalking and harassment to
terrify and frighten victims but it's
not really something we have specific
data on but technology is a tool that is
used more frequently all the time
representative newman
thank you mr chair
um
i'm i'm thinking off the top of my head
about as i'm reading this in the
discussion that talks about images to
people who are 50 are
less than 16 years old
and i'm thinking about um
where
a 15-year-old is intimate with a
older teenager or another teenager
and they send pictures to their friends
i i don't know if that happens but i
presume that it may happen would that
person be charged with a felony
if it was a minor who committed who
actually distributed that if it would be
appropriate i'd prefer to defer that
question to the prosecutor because i
think he'll have the most comprehensive
knowledge on that
thank you
representative wrong
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um we had a situation in merrimack a few
years ago where a teacher sent
images like this to a student who was 16
or older
and i was wondering are there any
statutes on the book that books that
you're aware of that would
provide more criminal
charges in that situation because i
could see you could have a high school
student at 17
and is under the power of a teacher but
that still would only be a misdemeanor
with this legislation absolutely we did
submit a list of the related statutes um
on the back of our testimony but again i
think the prosecutor is probably the
person best suited to answer the
questions about charging decisions okay
thank you thank you for your question
though
thank you for your time thank you mr
chairman
the committee now calls steve andres
merrimack county attorney's
uh office morning again my name is
stephen henderson i'm an assistant
county attorney in merrimack county um
as i indicated earlier i've been a
prosecutor for over 20 years
so i'd be happy to try and answer some
of the questions about how we would go
about prosecuting these cases or
what we would do in certain scenarios
i can indicate the scenario of
if you texted someone a picture
intending to text it to one person
it accidentally went to another person i
would
personally look at that scenario
very much in the same context of
if i had an individual who said
i was going to surprise my wife by
jumping out naked in front of her and
happened to have
jumped out naked in front of the wrong
person
um i would look at whether or not that
was reasonable
um
i would look at the two phone numbers i
would look at whether they were
a digit off or completely different
i'd look at
whether there was evidence that this
person had done this in the past and all
that would go into
a decision whether or not to charge the
person
i don't know if anybody has any
questions
if the chair may inquire and thank you
for your testimony thank you for taking
my question
is there any
is any opinion on the so it says
on lines line 7
it references an image
would it change the
intent or the how this vlog would be
applied if it's an image or a lot live
video feed if we maybe just tighten that
up
i
i don't see that as
is
necessary i don't know that that would
necessarily
be necessary because i don't know that a
live stream
would not be considered an image
at least to me
if somebody had was live streaming
themself
um fornicating to a person over 16
i don't know that i would say well it
wasn't an image because it was a live
stream
representative bert you were recognized
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony
again back to that scenario of um
if a couple are together
and then they break up
and they come and see you or the police
and then see you right yeah look what's
happening
how are you going to determine
that there was consent or there wasn't
consent
i think what it would come down to is
when i look at this statute we would
have to prove beyond a reasonable doubt
at trial that the recipient has not
indicated by speech or conduct
that they freely consented to the
receipt of the image
so i would look at
the
the background of that relationship i
think that you'd likely have
the person perhaps saying at one point
this was consensual
and if they didn't explicitly then
indicate it is no longer consensual
i think we would not be able to bring
charges in that case
follow up mr chair
representative you recognize for a
follow-up thank you
now another scenario is i received an
email
that i was in as an attachment
i was not going to open it up because i
didn't recognize it good idea yes
well
well then i get a text john opened this
email
and
the email was from australia
so when i inquired about that because i
looked into it a little further i go
this thing's from australia i'm not
opening it so when i inquired it was
from somebody i knew and they have
software that don't put them in new
hampshire they put it puts them in
australia and i'm going how does this
happen
so i'm i'm confused on how it happens
but i guess it does how are we going to
enforce this law with somebody sitting
in new hampshire
emailing down to australia or that's
where the ip goes and comes back
i think it would be very difficult to
enforce under that scenario um
but that's something that we face
with
with all sorts of laws whether it's a
outside of
whether this bill passes or not that's a
problem in law enforcement that we see
in terms of people
harassing threatening
committing financial crimes committing
online
fraud
is that people are able to hide their
their
actual location or their ip address
through software
representative klein knight
um thank you chair
are you saying that's what
investigations are for
certainly that would be part of the
investigation i think
you could certainly frustrate an
investigation
representative roy you're recognized
thank you
um in reviewing the statute it it talks
um about images of yourself
but it doesn't seem to cover um
just random images that could still be
offensive would that be covered under
the gross lewdness part of the statue or
does it need the statute perhaps need to
include
any uh
lurid images
or and i know there's been some issues
with a definition of pornography
to include for example cartoons like
manga or whatever
what are your thoughts on that
i think that the
the language in this statute that refers
to an image of himself or herself
fornicating exposing his or her genitals
mirrors the language that already exists
in 645-1 with reference to people under
16.
i certainly do think that
i don't want to say that
there's a loophole but this statute
wouldn't cover
sending a picture of another person's
genitals and i think that
that currently
if you sent a picture of another
person's genitals to a person under 18
we could conceivably charge that with
providing minors with harmful materials
which is
um
i don't know if i know that statute off
the top of my head i want to say it's in
the
series it's in the public justice
section
so there is a statute that prohibits um
exposing minors to harmful materials
by sending them a picture of genitals
for a person under 18.
i believe that's a misdemeanor
follow-up
president of rory recognized for a
follow-up at the
at the risk of delving into this alone
too deep
how
for example you charge
me with sending a photo to someone under
the statute
and i say
that's not mine
are we doing how do you do that
is that a line up for me
and again this mirrors language that's
already in
the statute that prosecutors already
have
you know difficulty proving
i think realistically though this
this is less about random people sending
pictures of their genitals to other
random people yeah and i think this
is more of a
you meet on a dating website you
exchange a couple emails you
know who this person is and they send
you a picture
and make some comment about
look at my spectacular genitals yeah and
are admitting that this is in fact a
photo of themselves
um follow-up
i i i totally agree with the the
sentiment and
and most of the statute i just want to
make sure that we make it enforceable i
don't want to pass something that feels
great but isn't workable so if you have
a suggestion we would appreciate it
you certainly could expand the uh
the
his or her genitals to
human genitals or any genitals or
whatever language you felt was
appropriate for that
representative schultz
thank you mr chair did i understand you
correctly to say you had a concern about
maybe it wasn't concerned but that you
didn't believe the word image
would also reference video
i believe the word image would reference
video okay
i agree thank you
representative newman
did you uh mention that that image is
defined in the current law 645.1 i don't
believe it is defined in six forty five
one
thank you
representative wrong
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
i don't know if you remember the
question i asked miss schulich but
um we had a situation in merrimack where
a teacher was sending images of himself
to a student who was 16
and with this is there any statute that
you're aware of that would
elevate that crime
over something
maybe a non-teacher doing it
i'm not aware of anything that would
make it more illegal for a teacher to do
that
okay thank you
representative bolden
thank you for taking my question so i
know that um the questions so far have
covered a lot of different concerns
about the terminology
with the intent being
to
[Music]
extend the indecent exposure
law to the internet
are there any changes that you'd
recommend to the wording and i know i'm
kind of putting you on the spot but if
you could say generally
i don't see any changes that i would
recommend i don't know that this
necessarily extends it to the internet
it would
extend it to somebody
um
providing it transmitting it to another
person
whether that be through text or email
but i don't think this would necessarily
you know criminalize someone from
putting a picture on their website
thank you for your testimony thank you
at this time we'll now close the public
hearing on house bill 1388
just uh the members of the community in
a minute or two we're going to open the
executive session on
house bill
1340.
uh
at this time we are now opening the
executive session on house bill 1340
relative to the definition of domestic
violence and relative to
criminal convictions for domestic
violence at this time the chair
recognizes representative klein knight
to make a motion
i move that we itl this bill it's a
motion for any speeding to legislate is
there a second
it's been
seconded by representative bradley
do you wish to speak to your motion i i
have a point at um a question for the
chair parliamentary inquiry yes um did
did you just say representative bradley
i did
she seconded them oh sorry
she had her hand you're absolutely right
she did that
i have no question for the chair i am
very sorry and i just for the record
need representative bradley say
second
thank you
chair could you just repeat the bill
number please
we are in the executive session for
house bill 1340 there is a motion of
inexplaining to legislate
representative perez
thank you mr speaker
for letting me speak
um
i
i want to speak on this bill
i'm someone who um
is a survivor of domestic violence
to be honest
um
i
i was only 15 years old when i moved
here
to the us
um i didn't know the language i didn't
know my rights
i was hiding
on a closet when my ex-husband used to
hit me
the neighbor used to call the cops
and he used to hide me in the closet and
he used to tell me not to get out of the
closet
because he didn't want to get in trouble
with the cops
so he never got in trouble for
domestic violence
this bill
it would take away the rights for
victims like myself
to
be able to put charges to someone
like my ex-husband who
not only
he
he hit me but
mentally and emotionally he
abused me
he took away my two kids
because he told me that if i put any
charges
for domestic violence against him
he was gonna take away my kids from me
and he was gonna take my right to be in
this country
me not knowing very well the language
i believe him
my son he was two years old
my daughter was six years old
when he took them to north carolina
i was afraid to lose my
my right to be in this country
and not be able to see my kids never
again
that son that needed
i wish i knew my rights
back in the days
because i felt like he took away the
right for me to be a mother
and the right for me
for my kids to have a mother
i feel guilty
i feel sad that i didn't have the chance
to be there for my daughter when she was
growing up
i will
support the ideal for this bill because
trust me
it's many ways
domestic violence happened
especially for people like myself
when we don't know what is right and
what is wrong
thank you
representative rhodes you are recognized
thank you mr speaker
i'm sorry i i was following
representative perez um thank you mr
chairman i
i think
the the state has worked very hard to be
where we currently are with with the
laws in protecting victims of domestic
violence and
i think it is imperative that we keep
the measures in place to help these
victims especially considering that we
had a very good piece of legislation
that would have helped these victims
with their abusers and unfortunately we
were not able to get that legislation
passed
this time the the matter will now be put
to question if you were in support of
the motion of inexpedient to legislate
please say yay if you were opposed
please say nay
the clerk will now call the role
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch
hi
representative burt
yes
representative rhodes
representative greene yes
clerk votes yes representative testerman
representative lang yes
representative pratt
yes
representative marston
representative harriet gathright
representative schultz yes
representative wrong yes
representative bordnay yes
representative perez
yes
representative newman yes
representative bolden yes
representative conley yes
representative klein knight yes
representative bradley
chairman abbas
chair votes yes
21-0
move consent
no objections
with the majority report
that will be prepared by representative
bradley thank you very much
this time we will now close the
executive session house bill 1340.
the committee will be in recess until
12 pm
i know
you could probably
i'm like
um
i guess done in consideration for
something else i guess some people are
um paying people to paying couples to do
things online i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna mention or go into detail
but
uh technically it theoretically could be
considered uh money in exchange for sex
so it because of the the broad way that
our
uh prostitution and related offenses are
defined are very broad in new hampshire
that that they could be caught under
that
scope
so
i didn't i didn't want to see
cases where people are just doing a
webcam or doing doing something like
that they may even be a couple and they
could still
theoretically get prosecuted so this is
meant to protect them also
my biggest concern
was when i was living in manchester i
started to see more and more often that
sex workers were were out in the street
and what happens in most western
countries is they they recognize that
there's a problem but they either
tolerate it they decriminalize it
they've
legalized sex work or
regulate it in some way
in order to get it off the street and
some western countries have some type of
red light district or pink like district
of some kind in a commercial setting
um but most of them it's allowed only in
the privacy of your own home
and that's just that's just to get the
activity off the street and that's kind
of what what my intent was
i have had a few
people i've known over the years
actually get caught up in this who were
not engaged in prostitution at all and
they still got they were still arrested
they were still charged and they still
end up with a criminal record they ended
up at the valley street jail
even though they were not actually
sex workers in any true sense of the
word
and the reason is
that something as simple as photography
can potentially fall under this penumbra
because it's so broad
and so what i've tried to do is come up
with
a very simple carve out to say
that if somebody's just in the privacy
of their own home that we're not going
to have enforcement in new hampshire
towns do retain the ability
to find somebody ten dollars on a first
offense or fifty dollars on a second
time offense but i i wouldn't i i can't
imagine too many towns or cities
actually uh
going ahead and trying to to enforce
this violation level offense they could
if they they really really needed to
or if they really really um if there
were public support for that it's it's a
local control issue but
i didn't think
i didn't think that it's a good use of
of
of public resources to go into people's
homes and
and try to punish them for what they're
doing the privacy of their own home
we have seen that when prostitution is
made illegal in general that it ends up
out in the street
and that because of the arrests women
mostly women working
end up having to get a pimp and the pimp
is usually where the abuse comes in
some serial killers have admitted that
they they target
uh prostitutes
because they found that they're easier
targets that they're isolated we passed
an immunity law a couple of years ago
through this committee
um to guarantee that the women who are
working in that in that field are able
to go to the the police without risking
prosecution but it's not a it's not a
completely uh
universal
immunity
that they have they still are actually
risking being arrested if they come
forward and report a crime
so
for that reason
and others i felt that the bill was
necessary um i tried to come up with
every possible compromise that any
member of this committee has ever
brought up that where they had a concern
that there wasn't
people weren't using condoms or they
weren't using protection or there were
um that some people weren't getting
tested so i tried to
accommodate every possible uh
uh concern that people had and it's uh
in this particular version of the bill
it's limited just to one's own home so
it's
it
you still wouldn't be allowed to
solicit outside you wouldn't be allowed
to advertise under the bill you wouldn't
be allowed to
even
the issue of promoting it on the
internet you still wouldn't be allowed
that aspect of it isn't legalized or
decriminalized
the only thing that's allowed under this
the only thing that's decriminalized is
people engaging in any type of sexual
activity in their own home
so with that i'll take i'll take
questions
representative rhodes you're recognized
thank you mr chairman
i
i feel like there's a smorgasbord of
questions here um
so representative
how
so if a person hires
if somebody hires a person
and and then they're supposed to go have
you know this test
i'm sorry a person hires somebody uses a
false name
because i'm sure they probably don't
want you know
their name to be all through that
newspaper
so
in this legislation you have about the
person having to be tested yearly for
sexually transmitted diseases and how
exactly
would this sex worker go about notifying
their clients that
they can just take an annual test and if
they really want to post it on the wall
like
you know when you go into the
chiropractor or dentist's office and
they have their license i'm sure that
they can post it on the wall if they
wanted to if anybody
objected
or if anyone raised a question about it
i think that if somebody were actually
going to go
and use you know
hire this kind of service that they
should probably use a condom regardless
just as a matter of safety and in fact
90 plus percent of the time people
are doing that right now
um
but i
i
i've never even considered
you know someone going in and then and
then wanting to check the license on the
wall for that
i don't know
if somebody wanted to they could just
they could post that up on the wall in
the bedroom i suppose
representative newman you were
recognized
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
i i just want to make sure that i am
correctly reading this bill as it's
written in front of me
um
and you can correct me if i'm wrong
and everything on page one and
everything on page two except for the
one portion that is uh parentheses
parenthesis z on parentheses
where you it's lined out
and it lines all of that line out and
then it continues to line out into the f
there
means that that is the only part of the
current law that is taken out
in the way this is written then
paragraph that used to be f is now
paragraph e but that's that's the only
language that's taken out of the bill as
i see it
and the rest is the bill right that's a
strategy that's used by legislative
services when they instead of just
completely rewriting the whole thing
they take on the first part all they've
done is remove part e which is
knowingly permits
a place under the person's control to be
used for in violation of a subparagraph
and then there's a new paragraph added
which is uh on page two starting on line
six
thank you yeah i see that thank you very
much
representative martin
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
is there a
any or a large amount of
law enforcement going into our private
homes
for this type of an arrest
right now i don't know of any the only
the only city i know where there was a
lot of enforcement of prostitution laws
was the city of manchester when i lived
there and
what they were mainly going after was
what was going on on the street i
believe they were also going into
lodging
and the reason that they were doing that
was only because there was a federal
grant that said that the city had to
spend the money enforcing prostitution
laws that was the only one that i was
aware of that was on a large scale
thank you
thank you representative
did you have a question
i saw a hand go up over there i didn't
know
the committee now calls gene pride
do you mind if i take this down it's a
little easier to speak
thank you
good morning thank you very much for the
opportunity to testify to this bill to
chairman abbas and vice chairman roy i
appreciate it very much my name is
jeanne pride and i am from swansea new
hampshire i'm here to testify against
house bill 1176.
i've taught high school for 29 years
mostly at conant high school in jaffrey
new hampshire
and teaching child development has
always been my passion for the last
several years i've been teaching a human
development course through river valley
community college
also i'm the board i'm on the board of
rise for baby and family of keen which
provides intervention for children zero
to three i'm not here to represent these
institutions but just to indicate my
concern for children and their welfare
there are others here who are testifying
today that have much more expertise on
the concerns result regarding this bill
but allow our
prostitution to be legalized what i want
to concentrate on is the harm to
children this bill states that by
keeping prostitution illegal we are
contributing to the improvisation
of single mothers and their children
the idea of a single mother having men
in her home while her children are there
is very dangerous darkness to light is a
non-profit whose mission is to end
child sexual abuse they cite research
that children who live in a single
parent and has a living partner are the
highest rate of sexual abuse they are 20
times more likely to be victims of
sexual abuse than children who live with
both parents
research fellow jeremy summit cites
reviews of more than 70 research reports
providing overwhelming evidence that
girls living in non-traditional families
are sexually abused by step fathers
partners of the single remarried or
partner mothers at many times
the rate abused by a biological father
there are men coming into the home who
have no connection to the children and
are coming only the purpose of sex this
i believe can be a dangerous situation
for the children
i have here for each of you some
information on what is called paces and
aces
what ace is is adverse childhood
experience this has been pretty well
accepted at most schools
and how we treat children these days
what aces is is childhood experience
that harms children's developing brains
so profoundly that the effects show up
decades later they can cut they cause
much of the chronic disease mental
illness and at the root of most violence
this is my greatest concern for these
children that in these situations they
would experience aces due to these men
coming into their home the aces can not
only be sexual abuse but hearing yelling
perhaps violence against her mother and
other abuses
there are means in which our state and
schools help single mothers get the
education they need for their families
they would be much healthier for them
and their children
this is what we need to be promoting the
course i teach human development is a
requirement at river valley nursing
program a large percentage of my
students are single moms i tell them
this is the best thing you can do right
now for your family
these are the things we should be
promoting i strongly urge that you do
not support this bill thank you
there being no questions thank you for
your testimony
the committee now calls darlene pollock
good morning mr chairman ladies and
gentlemen members of the committee i
appreciate you hearing me today my name
is darlene for the record and
i'm a resident of raymond new hampshire
i'm also a juvenile sex trafficking
survivor from here in new hampshire
this bill
specifically outlines the quite the
experience that i had because it doesn't
just say in your home it says or where
you're legally allowed to be
my first trafficker groomed me at 13
years old at 14 years old on my birthday
he sold me for the first time in his
apartment
in his bed
i was just turned 14.
you hear me right the day before i was
13 years old
about a year and a half later this same
buyer rented an apartment where he had a
stable a stable is a term for the for
that we use when you have more than one
sex trafficked child or
persons there were three of us girls at
the time when i was living there and he
furnished us generously with narcotics
and and
a lot of
a lot of generosity went on if we were
very compliant if we were not we were
threatened very seriously not only with
violence but with being turned out into
the street etc
it wasn't a violent experience in that
place for me but we did suffer a lot of
deprivations if we didn't comply we
didn't get any food he would go away on
vacation and leave us with nothing we
weren't allowed to leave or we would not
be allowed to come back
this situation only again lasted a few
months
but i was trafficked for four years
and i want to just let you know that
because i'm sitting here and i look okay
you might think well that was just a
childhood experience it's no big deal
but i have suffered my entire life with
all kinds of symptoms from chronic
illness and pain constantly to symptoms
similar to post-traumatic stress
disorder nightmares inability to make
decisions i own nothing because i can't
make long-term decisions
i have suffered on and off with
substance abuse and with alcoholism i
have a lot of trauma responses in my
life that i manage with a great deal of
diligence and a lot of struggle
this is not a small thing the
representative introduced this bill
saying in one's own home
about 15 times
but if you look at that bill it says or
in a place where they're legally able to
be
that's a big difference from in one's
own home
i ask you to vote inexpedient to
legislate on house bill 1176 and i'll
now take questions but i would ask you
to please keep them
to the testimony given here today thank
you
there being no questions that the
committee appreciates you sharing thank
you for your testimony thank you
the committee now calls tricia grant
first i just want to say thank you for
allowing me this opportunity to speak um
i like my like my survivor sibling
before me i'm a survivor of sex
trafficking
i was trafficked as a 15 year old child
in and out of maine new england
all over the place in people's homes
i was brought into people's homes so
this bill just floors me i can't even
i've had three days to kind of process
this and i'm shaking
like this is insane to me that
there are people even considering doing
this
and i'm just gonna continue on with what
i have written but
i was brought into people's homes
i was brought into hotels legally
operated strip clubs that are still
fully functioning
all against my will
i did not want to be at any of these
places
i was told that if i did not go to these
that the people who had trafficked me
would have my son taken away from me
because i had been living on my own
since i was 12
and living in my own apartment going to
school and working and taking care of my
son at 14 years old
these men knew what my biggest
what my biggest fear was and they
exploited that they told me that if i
did not do everything that they told me
to do they would have my son taken away
from me
walking alongside survivors of all ages
and the long-term impacts
like darlene has stated
are some of the things that i myself
have experienced and the other survivors
that i walk alongside
and
just because we are removed from that
situation does not mean that it all of a
sudden just goes away
the long-term impacts of people being
trafficked exploited and who have
experienced prostitution
even if they
even if they believe that they have been
there as a willing participant
these effects still remain
some of those are cptsd anxiety
struggles with self-worth suicidal
ideation
suicide
i myself attempted suicide so many times
i don't even remember how many
the last suicide attempt i had was when
i was 23
and i had to learn how to walk again
all of this because of the trauma that i
experienced as a child and my experience
being exploited
legalizing prostitution has never been
an effective strategy to keep people
safe because there is absolutely no way
to know who is there by choice and who
isn't
how old a person is
nobody was asking me to see my state id
or to see my birth certificate and i can
guarantee you even if they had
my trafficker would have found a way to
have a fake id made so there is
absolutely no way to guarantee that
somebody is there by will and of age
and to just kind of
speak to
the fact that
somebody stated earlier that it's the
responsibility of the person who
is selling sex
to be tested once a year
sometimes those tests don't become clear
for six months nine months
sometimes
it just floors me that that was even
presented but the thing that floors me
most is that what about the men who are
coming in to buy or what about the
people in general
who are there to come in and buy sex
what's the responsibility on their end
to be tested
i'm going to end just by stating that it
took me 16 years to even know that there
was a name for what happened to me
and that it wasn't my fault
i never spoke of what happened to me for
16 years i sat in that silence i sat in
that pain
terrified to go into grocery stores
because i might run into somebody who
paid for me
16 years ago
that's that's trauma
that does not just go away
that carries on with people who have
stated that they are willing
participants and people who are not
so i'm just going to ask you i'm just
going to end on this please
please do not let this pass this is not
safe it is not a way to help people
as much as people
can try to claim that it is it just
simply is not
it took me another year and a half after
i learned that there was a name for what
happened to me and that it wasn't my
fault to say something and since then i
have been able to be a fierce advocate
for myself
and for other people who are still
walking through this and for people who
remained in their bondage of silence
even longer than i did
please do not let this pass i will at
this point take any questions anybody
has
there been no questions the witnesses
thanked for her testimony cheering
the committee calls marissa fulcans
i'm sorry if i mispronounced that
hi there thank you for hearing me my
name is marissa fernandez i am the
national director of new hampshire
traffic free coalition
and um
i live in new hampshire and i
wanted to speak today in opposition to
this bill i've been working the
anti-trafficking world for 13 years and
i'm horrified to see how much this would
set us back as a state and as a as a
nation if we were to
condone a bill like this that has so
many things that would harm women inside
of it and put them at greater risk of
being trafficked
so
one of the things that is there's a the
london school of economics did a
big research paper and they found that
wherever
sex was legal the demand for it
increased and
sex trafficking increased
so it's a just simple economics where
where there is a demand
you have to have more product and so
that's what's happening when you look at
like las vegas or germany certain places
in germany and the netherlands
um this is a big issue because people
know they can go there and buy sex and
if you're an entrepreneur or if you know
you can um
make more money as a result of this
situations like darlene's
um
will happen
more often because they want to
be able to get as much money and have as
much product as they possibly can to
meet that demand
um
it also would make new hampshire a sex
tourist destination which would put the
women that i work with at greater risk
and the people we're trying to protect
at greater risk
um and i also as a mother with three
boys i don't want my children growing up
thinking they can purchase another human
being
for sex and i think it really sets us
back
um
as a movement like even as from a
feminist perspective to think that um
women can be bought and sold and that
they're an object to fulfill a specific
gratification of another individual so i
i post it on that level as well
so some of the other points were made
but um
yeah i think i asked for it for two
minutes but yes i would just ask you to
consider is this something we want in
our state is this something that we want
to condone we want our
young children growing up thinking that
especially women can be bought and sold
as predominantly women
who are
in prostitution
we need to be creating exit strategies
this is not the best we can do for the
women of new hampshire thank you
oh if anyone has any
questions there being no questions the
witnesses excuse thank you for your
testimony
the committee calls pamela kylie and
janet carroll
new hampshire coalition against domestic
and sexual violence
good afternoon mr chair and members of
the committee my name is pamela keilig
and i am the public policy specialist at
the new hampshire coalition against
domestic and sexual violence you've
heard from us several times this morning
so i won't reiterate who we are
but we are strongly opposed to hb 1176
which would have an extremely harmful
impact on the victims of sexual assault
and human trafficking in our state
and i am grateful to have my colleague
janet carroll here today who is going to
provide some educational information
around the major concerns we have with
this legislation
good morning
for the record my name is janet carroll
and i'm the statewide sexual assault
nurse examiner program director uh with
the coalition
uh there are three main areas that i
hope to address in my testimony one is
clarification on what the general court
finds in this legislation impact that
this legislation will have on victims of
sexual assault and human trafficking
based on the experiences they have now
and the illumination of the
comprehensive health care needs victims
of sexual assault and human trafficking
have as it relates to the risk and
prevention of sexually transmitted
infections or stis and hiv
first
from a medical perspective the article
that was listed which references
researchers at ucla and baylor
university who discover a reduction in
rape and stis during a time when indoor
prostitution was inadvertently
decriminalized in rhode island
i've included that article for your
reference
from a medical perspective it's really
important to note that this paper has
not been peer reviewed but rather
circulated for discussion and comment
purposes only
in addition the authors clearly state
quote we are not claiming to have
identified the casual channels which
link decriminalization unquote
to the reducti rejections that they
discuss
second i'd like to address the
suggestion that uh criminal
criminal
offense of sex work is leading to the
pandemic of sexual violence
sexual violence including human
trafficking occurs across all
socioeconomic populations regardless of
an individual's choice of employment it
is forced manipulated or coerced sexual
activity in which the perpetrator uses
sex to inflict humiliation exert power
and control or use the victim to attain
sexual gratification without regard to
the victim's consent
the responsibility for that sexual
violence lies squarely at the feet of
the offenders who are rarely if ever
held accountable holding offenders
accountable by legalizing their activity
is unfathomable and extremely dangerous
to further suggest that in holding
offenders accountable we are in some way
contributing to the rate of sexual
violence it's outrageous it minimizes
the very real abusive and traumatizing
experience that victims of human
trafficking and sexual assault face
the impact the second area would be the
impact of this legislation on victims of
sexual assault and human trafficking
based on the experiences they have now
i know that members of the human
trafficking task force are here today to
address the significant concerns that
arise from this legislation but i'd like
to just highlight a couple
from someone who frequently provides
care to those
patients experiencing sexual assault and
human trafficking
with treatment and care okay
sexual assault including human
trafficking is already severely unre
under reported and there are significant
bias and victim blaming when the adult
sex worker reports
sexual assault
which contributes to no reporting or
under reporting of this crime when it
does occur
when victims feel it is unsafe to report
not only are offenders not held
accountable but the victims themselves
do not get the access to treatment and
resources that they need
this bill will actually place victims at
more risk because it will reduce their
access to critical protections and
support
many victims of human trafficking are
not identified at all due to the lack of
education and understanding about the
differences between trafficking and
prostitution this legislation will
assist in making it more difficult to
identify the victims of trafficking
i routinely care for children and adults
who are forced or coerced into providing
sex whether it be for money food shelter
or something else
this legislation increases the
likelihood that those individuals will
be harder to find identify and properly
care for
the third area illumination of the
comprehensive healthcare needs for
victims of sexual assault and human
trafficking as it relates to the risk
and prevention of sexually transmitted
infections including hiv
victims of violence and victims of human
trafficking
present for health care in similar ways
but victims of human trafficking are
more likely to be isolated
abuse drugs and have infectious diseases
malnutrition and complications from poor
medical care
victims of human trafficking have some
of the most profound medical and
psychological health problems including
sexually transmitted infections genital
mutilation urinary difficulties
pregnancy resulting from rape broken
bones burns concussions dental problems
and infections in addition to post
traumatic stress disorder anxiety and
depression
victims of human trafficking need timely
access to health care and treatment that
is comprehensive and reflective of their
experiences and the exploitation that
they face
providing this essential care would be
nearly impossible under this new
legislation which will only increase the
barriers that victims face to accessing
the care and support they critically
need
it is also in the best interest of the
state and its citizens to implement
public policy that serves to improve the
circumstances of sexual assault and
human trafficking victims in new
hampshire
we should be putting forth every effort
to address the root cause of violence
not create further opportunities for
abuse and exploitation
in conclusion the realities of sexual
assault and human trafficking new
hampshire have far-reaching consequences
for victims in the communities which
they live
victims often experience a lifetime of
trauma including both acute and chronic
physical and mental health consequences
and the coalition and the sane program
believe this legislation will cause
greater difficulty and identification of
victims and further harm
by limiting health care ability to
provide support and critical treatment
there being no questions the witnesses
of thanks for their testimony
we now call charles
pendlebury representing msco
good afternoon mr chair and members of
the committee my name is charles
pendlebury i've been in law enforcement
for 10 years two of which i've served on
the new hampshire human trafficking task
force i am here speaking as a
representative of the merrimack county
sheriff's office in opposition to hb
which would be detrimental to the safety
of human trafficking victims
i would like to briefly share a few
facts that we know to be true from our
experience to investigate and charge
crimes of human trafficking in the state
identifying sex trafficking is extremely
difficult because of tactics used by
traffickers
this bill would further complicate
efforts to come to combat sex
trafficking specifically law enforcement
officers would now lack probable cause
to enter a home or building under this
new law
as the bill essentially legalizes
brothels without any protections for
victims of human trafficking
traffickers are known to use violence
and intimidation to force their victims
into commercial sex
they further brainwash their victims to
believe that police cannot be trusted
and are only there to wreck their lives
sex trafficking victims struggle to
identify their own victimization
this is a crime that is happening in the
shadows
victims are not reporting this crime
because they are under a delusion
created by the trafficker
that what they are doing is at their own
free will
sex traffickers will use this
legislation to convince their victims
that this activity is legal this will
only embolden the traffickers
to increase their ability to control the
activities of their victims
i can honestly say that i've never
arrested anyone in my time as a law
enforcement officer
for prostitution and currently it is not
a common practice in new hampshire for
sex workers to be prosecuted and in some
counties there have been less than five
cases in the last three years
even if a sex worker is arrested it is
highly unlikely that they will be
convicted of the crime often due to
later correctly being identified as a
victim of human trafficking
with that in mind it is very confusing
to me as to who we are actually trying
to protect with this legislation
additionally monitoring the crime of
human trafficking is already extremely
difficult and this legislation will make
it nearly impossible
i would like to briefly talk about
familiar trafficking which to me is
up there is one of the most horrendous
forms of this crime
where
parents and guardians
will often trade their child
or person they are in custodial care of
to fuel a substance abuse addiction or
something like that and to me if this is
passed
it will only embolden them and make them
feel they can do whatever they want in
their home or place they have legal
right with no repercussions
i appreciate your time and i can answer
any questions that the committee may
have
there being no questions thank you for
your testimony
the committee calls michael shively
hello i'm michael shively i'm
representing the national center on
sexual exploitation
i'm a career researcher and most of it
is applied research in the fields of
criminal justice and victims issues
and i'm going to mostly restrict what i
say to the factual foundation that was
put forward in this bill
there's so many things wrong with it
that it's kind of hard to know where to
start and we'd be here all day if i just
fact checked everything in it but i'm
more than happy to provide information
like the details later but
i'll just touch over the kind of the low
lights of what's presented and just
offer some you know counter facts or a
little bit of reality check on it
um before i get into that though just a
little perspective that i can't help but
thinking
i just can't help but think of
it wasn't that long ago when domestic
violence was considered a family matter
it's something it's in the home it's
their business the state has no business
wading into homes and
worrying about what's going on there
this just seems like we're we're headed
back you know it seems like you're
taking what is undoubtedly the most
dangerous way to make money that exists
on the planet
the evidence is absolutely overwhelming
that nothing is more dangerous than
commercial sex
and it doesn't matter what legal system
it operates under it's always dangerous
and it's endemic and you can't do harm
reduction it just it doesn't get reduced
right it if it exists it's dangerous now
you're saying let's take this insanely
dangerous thing
and it's a it's private business as long
as it's indoors
that's like saying you know like all
this family stuff we we can't sort it
out so just let it go right
so that's that's the perspective but
um
there's a lot of research on this in
fact there are over 700 000 studies and
factual reports about it so it's
possible to come out of that
avalanche of facts and reports and come
up with anything you know i can support
any conclusion about it if what you do
is cherry pick just the stuff you want
which is what's happened this this reads
directly it's from the playbook of the
pro-decriminalization movement which is
a global movement and actually in that
movement new hampshire is just a point
on a map
and you're targeted you're being
targeted with disinformation and this
this uh
factual foundation that's in there it's
it's directly from the documentation
it's sort of like
you know going back to the tobacco
industry and if the only thing you
listened to was what the tobacco
industry said about smoking safety
that's what you have in front of you so
um i i really can't fact-check all of it
but basically everything there if their
grains of truth but they're
misrepresented
or they're part of a spectrum of
information and it's only one part and
you're not seeing the rest of it i'll
get into a couple of things but
there's no evidence that hiv declines
under decriminalization there's only one
decriminalized country in the in the
world it's new zealand right so what are
you going to compare to that to right
there's just no comps there there's some
estimates but they're really uh
problematic and they're very speculative
legalization has not worked in the
netherlands in fact the netherlands has
been kicking it around and they finally
recently decided in amsterdam
we need it out of the city we've not
been able to make this work and they're
pushing it out of the city finally um i
can talk about nevada i can talk about
anywhere it's been legalized that's not
what we're talking about here exactly
this is decriminalization which is kind
of the worst of all worlds you're not
setting up any real protections or
systems to try to make it safe
but you're also saying law enforcement
is not going to intervene one thing i
can guarantee you is that
if you decriminalize even if it's just
within this limited context of the home
you lose police lose probable cause to
investigate human trafficking new
zealand which is held up by some some
success story they just got knocked down
by the state department from a tier one
which means the best to a tier 2 country
because they don't make sex trafficking
cases anymore
any advocates groups tells you there are
hundreds of child sex trafficking
victims in the country
they've made zero
zero convictions and i identified zero
adult or child victims in the last three
years these are state department reports
um
the typical sex trafficking case is made
because you see prostitution there's
probable cause since it's a crime and
that's when they find out you know she
looks 20 but she's 14. or well it seems
consensual but as soon as she's away
from her pimp she says i this is this is
not consensual
you lose that um
one i'll just talk about one study and
then i'll stop that rhode island study
that was mentioned earlier
here's what happened with that study
rhode island
they had this weird little loophole that
kind of decriminalized it it started in
1980 it ended in 2009 what the study did
is they looked at these trend lines on
health indicators like h
you know like
sexually transmitted diseases they
looked at rape rates
and they picked the year
on sexual assault that was an anomaly it
was 49 higher than the previous year the
one that came after it
they picked 2003
and then they ended it in 2009. well if
you take this freak year
that's high and then say something
happened and it ended up lower it makes
it sound like it went down right
the whole trend line tells exactly the
opposite story so they took out of um
29 years time series they took their
favorite six years that's what the study
is based on
there's a lot of really horrible
research and then there's some good
facts that actually were good research
but if you misrepresent them they tell
the story that really isn't the true
story so um
i'm more than happy i've got i could
give you more research than you would
ever care to look at and i could support
anything i've said and i'm happy to go
point by point in that factual statement
in the in the bill
and offer at least another perspective
any questions
representative newman
thank you thank you for taking my
question
you know i i wouldn't want you to have
to go by
point by point
but i'm just curious if your research
has any
anything you could say from your
research that deals with uh
roman numeral two which is about the
harmful reduction countries i don't know
what that is
and and
that and also roman numeral six
which just mentions article 2b of the
new hampshire constitution i would be
interested in anything that your
research showed about or you could say
based on your research
yeah so there's a
a trend or a movement in the public
health field where um
uh for for reasons i could talk about
but it could take too much time
unless you want to um
there's a movement to to accept
decriminalization and it's mostly driven
by the industry itself and the industry
itself of course their economic
interests are to make more money and
keep the industry flourishing so
um in the public health world there
there's some adoption of this
decriminalization idea
and there are a lot of studies that they
all look the same pretty much which is
what they do is they go into a clinic
and they find that um you know there's
astronomical rates of all kinds of
horrible things for anyone involved in
the sex trade
and
then there's an assertion in the study
that says
it would be great if it was
decriminalized right that way the police
wouldn't harass people
so there's an assertion in there but
there's really no connection between
lowering hiv rates or any other health
problem
other than that assertion
there's one study by kate shannon showed
up in the lancet super famous very
widely cited
and they said they did an estimate
that's based on very complicated
statistical models
and i actually had a conversation with
the authors and i said was there any
data actual data in your models
that showed decriminalization i wonder
how you measure that do you take all the
criminalized and the decriminalized
countries you know i mean there's things
that i wonder about they said no
they had no data on decriminalization
what they did is they plugged in
assumptions and the assumptions used in
that study one
economy used to go to 100
violence against anyone in sex work
that's their phrase not mine goes to
zero percent zero percent police
harassment now
what in the world could possibly make
those things happen no no population of
any kind has a zero percent violence
rate but they say decriminalization
would produce that then with that
assumption they plug it into this
forecast model
you know so i mean if you really dig
under the hood there's just there really
is nothing like i i thought about giving
you kind of a glib answer at first
when he said what's that about and to
tell you truth i don't know you know i
really can't because there is no
evidence that
holds up that really substantiates that
um was there another point
yes
the other the other point was do you
have anything to say about article 2a of
the new hampshire constitution if that
relates to this in any way i i i can't
say i don't i don't know the new
hampshire constitution thank you very
much for that thank you
all right
thank you very much thank you there be
no further questions
the committee now calls caitlyn makus
macias
good afternoon my name is caitlin macias
and i'm here representing world without
exploitation we are the largest
anti-human trafficking coalition with
over 200 united states-based
organizations
and we work on creating a world that's
free from human trafficking and sexual
exploitation which we believe is a human
rights issue that's fueled by gender
racial and income inequalities
we are guided by survivors of the
commercial sex trade whose perspectives
are critical in developing just an
effective policies
i come to this work with a unique
perspective i work with world we but i'm
also a latinx woman and a student at the
columbia school of social work
i stand here in opposition or actually
sit here in opposition of
hb1176
in new hampshire that would remove
criminal penalties for indoor
prostitution
this bill and the ideology it represents
is a fundamental misunderstanding of the
realities of the sex trade and minimizes
the lived experiences of survivors of
commercial sexual exploitation it's
thoughtless to implement a policy that
encourages the sex trade to actually
expand during a global pandemic
this bill claims to actually help women
and children
and members of the lgbtq community
however repealing criminal laws that
prohibit operating premises for
prostitution or operating a brothel will
only put those communities in further
harm's way you will actually be giving
pimps and traffickers a playground to
exploit people
why do you want a violent industry like
the sex trade to actually expand
do you know the realities
prostitution and sex trafficking are
actually inextricably linked and fueled
by the demand for commercial sex
violence is actually incredibly
pervasive physical psychological and
emotional abuse that you've actually
heard from survivors today
even in the privacy of their own homes
indoor prostitution is dangerous no one
will be able to see inside these homes
the best example of why new hampshire
should not pass this bill is actually
rhode island and you've heard about this
today rhode island decriminalized indoor
prostitution between 1980 and 2009 as a
result the stand became
a regional sex tourism hub with high
rates of sex trafficking violence and
extensive criminal involvement promoting
the state to revert back and adopt
strict laws against the
sex trade in 2009
so by removing these types of penalties
new hampshire is not protecting
marginalized people in the sex trade you
will simply be making it easier for
someone to start an elicit massage
business or brothel in this state
without worrying about penalties
and so now you're asking me what is the
solution we must take a holistic
approach instead world we and our member
organizations support legislation that
specifically ensures that people in
prostitution do not face criminal
penalties but instead are provided exit
strategies and services like safe
housing and health care this is known as
the equality model
we also support policies that enable
people in the sex trade to report
violence and other crimes they have
experienced to law enforcement without
fear of arrest
we know that criminalizing those engaged
in the sex trade who are victims of
violence and exploitation is harmful and
does nothing to prevent human
trafficking and exploitation but we also
know that making it easier and less
risky for third party exploiters like
pimps and brothel owners to prop it off
of exploitation of others is actually
not the answer
please oppose
hb1176 thank you for your time i also
would like to pass around a letter
on this was actually signed by over 70
survivors some of them are from new
hampshire and some of them are
from across the country and there are
survivors of sex trafficking and also
prostitution so if you want to take a
look at the letter and read their names
it would make a great deal thank you so
much
thank you for your testimony that being
the last witness um we will be closing
the hearing on this i would like to take
a moment to thank all of the witnesses
for their vigilance and coming forward
today and testifying
and personally i'd like to apologize
that you had to do so thank you very
much the hearing is closed
we'll be in recess until 1 45.
is
discussions
hmm
um
uh
yes
do you have anything you need
my oh
uh
it's crazy
do this
you
hey representatives
oh
this bill puts so many people's lives in
danger it um it's an insult to so many
different
remember we'll suspend we're not allowed
to
speak to another member's motivations
behind filing a bill
so
such um an argument would be
inappropriate however
i i think the unintended consequences
perhaps are some of the consequences of
the bill you can speak of if it were to
pass the unintended consequences of this
bill would
put so many people's lives in danger
um
and also i want to for the record say
that
sex trafficking is horrible
and
people that are forced and taken and
forced into
uh
this kind of situation it's abhorrent
and we should take it serious
um but there's a difference between
sex trafficking
and
um sex work
and people that are professionals
and they give consent
and we have to be careful about how we
talk about things like this because
we're discriminating against an entire
group of people
if we don't
separate the two thank you
thank you representative
at this time the matter will now be put
to question if you were in support of
the
motion of enyx being to legislate please
say yay if you were opposed please say
nay the clerk will not call the roll
vice chairman roy
okay
representative welch
yes
representative burt
representative rhodes
yes
representative green yes clerk votes yes
representative testerman
representative lang yes
representative pratt
yes
representative marston
yes representative harriet gathright
representative schultz
yes
representative wrong yes
representative bordenay
yes
representative perez
representative newman
yes
representative bolden
representative casey conley excuse me
yes
representative klein knight yes
representative bradley
chairman abbas the chair votes yes
twenty to zero one not voting
promotion passes
move the consent
representative
harry kathleen
will it be a majority report
thank
you and this time we'll now close the
executive session
on house bill 1176
this time we will now open the public
hearing on
house bill 1400 prohibiting law
enforcement from using the scent of
marijuana as probable cause for a search
that's okay
this time we recognize representative
bolden represent amanda bolden to
introduce
house bill 1400
thank you i'll fill this out and hand it
to you when i'm done
um for the record
my name is amanda bolden i represent
hillsborough district 12.
the new hampshire supreme court has
determined that the senate marijuana
alone is not sufficient
for probable cause
this was decided as a result of
decriminalization as well as the
creation of medical cannabis programs in
our state literally the smell of
marijuana is not evidence of a crime
because it's not a crime in all cases
even though the supreme court has sorted
this out for us as a legislature we
can't rely on case law alone to maintain
law order
i put in this bill because i've learned
in my life that many things smell like
marijuana which are not illegal and are
not evidence of a crime
for example i learned last summer that
fresh green branches of maple
smell identical to marijuana when burned
skunk spray is often mistaken for
marijuana as well as the popular
oil-based fragrance known as patchouli
which can be found in many shampoos
soaps and body washes
i've also had many experiences in which
the smell of marijuana entered my
vehicle or my home due to the activity
of a person nearby but unknown to me
for example i've driven behind many
vehicles
in my lifetime that were driven by
someone partaking
and
the smell exited their vehicle and went
into mine my windows were down or my
vent was open
additionally
i've had a neighbor who would use
marijuana in the backyard
and we kept our windows open because the
weather was nice but we'd have to close
them when the neighbors started because
the smell would get into our house
and that's a nuisance in and of itself
having to close the windows on a nice
day
but it would be a much greater bother if
someone else's behavior was used as
grounds to enter my property
however all of these circumstances aside
i want to return to the new hampshire
supreme court case law
we can ensure law and order in this
state by relying on case law the courts
do not make law they interpret it
we need to formalize this in statute we
need to ensure that people who are not
engaging in illegal behavior and cannot
reasonably be suspected of such are
secure in their persons houses papers
and effects against unreasonable
searches and seizures
i'll take any questions thanks
representative testament
do you mean to
excuse me you mean to
forbid the use of the smell of
marijuana
as one of the parts of probable cause in
other words
certainly
a person
a policeman could uh use marijuana plus
a
marijuana cigarette or something else
you know sort of a totality of all the
issues all of the
the issues that are there can you would
that be okay
i think you're referring to the
the supreme court
decision and
um that is the intent is to reflect what
the supreme court's decided
which is that it
it shouldn't be used as the sole reason
representative marston
thank you mr thank you chairman
thank you for taking my question
what i'm not following in the in the
writing on the bill
is you say
after section 10
i can't find a section 10 in the book
it must have been some new law that came
in
that hasn't been printed into a book is
that possible
thank you for the question
i have a laptop so
if you just give me a minute
so it says rsa 595a after section 10.
so we look up new hampshire rsa
595a never live blog googling before
595a
section 10.
so
595a has 10 sections so after section 10
so it would be section um
or
it would be
yup and that's what it says in the first
line 595-8 colon 11 that's what it would
be called
it might have i answered your question
would you like would you like to see the
rsas well that's fine
the witness and the in the members to
suspend for a moment
the witness is a member of the committee
so this discussion is more appropriate
maybe for the executive session
okay
thank you
representative wrong
thank you mr chairman
representative would you believe that in
i got pulled over by a police officer my
car was searched
on the the suspicion of marijuana
because he this officer detected a scent
it turned out to be a pinhole leak in my
radiator hose and the smell of burning
antifreeze
is very similar to
to cannabis so um in addition to those
examples you cited
did you would you believe that would you
believe that antifreeze is the same
smell would did you say that it was
can i answer the question
is the question that do you believe the
smell of burning antifreeze
is i think she was asking if i believe
that if that occurred and i don't
remember if you said the 70s but if it's
the 70s i might have my doubts okay
that's all thank you any additional
questions
representative harry catherine
i asked karen to print it a little bit
ago i think she'll bring it in soon um
or she'll ask me to come get it and i'll
hand it to you
into the chairman inquire of one
question
is this intent it says an officer shall
not use the scent of marijuana's
probable cause
do you are you suggesting just the scent
alone would not establish probable cause
or
it can't be considered as part of our
totality with other considerations
um i think that i already answered that
question earlier
with representative testerman
alone i apologize if i okay thank you if
i missed the answer i do apologize to
the witness thank you
the witness is excused
representative testman you are
recognized
when you stated
that it
couldn't be used alone and consistent
with the supreme court decision
if you read regardless of that if you
read
what
representative abbas was saying
it says you shall not use the senate of
marijuana as probable cause that would
tell me
that you could not use it at all not if
it's not part of something else but you
know
i do you
what do you mean there i mean i know
what your bill says but what you said
appears to contradict that
thank you for the question
my question is he said what do you mean
i think i think i answered that in your
earlier question um the scent of
marijuana alone should not be probable
cause
for a search
which is what our house smells like
sometimes my question
is that what the bill says
last question representative
it
i believe that the bill says that um
because it says as probable cause to
conduct a search and it doesn't say um
alone but it doesn't say in addition to
anything else so i think that that is
the intent is clear to me
i know that my communications with ols
my intent was clear
thank you the witness is excused
the committee calls the honorable jess
edwards
uh thank you for the record i'm
representative jess edwards uh
representing auburn chester and sandown
i signed in in opposition to this bill
i've already learned something though i
didn't realize that there was a supreme
court case that spoke to this matter
i would
still be tempted to go one of two
directions that's different than this
bill
i would either not
pass this into the rsas because the
supreme court decision is already in
effect
and the court can modify and tweak it
you know according to
future cases
or
i would go ahead and amend it
so that the word
solely is inserted in an appropriate
spot to make grammatical sense
so that it's clear that the smell alone
or solely the smell
um
would not be on its own uh probable
cause so i think i i
listen to the conversation i just think
a simple word tweak could fix it
and i guess i just would also
since this is a criminal justice
committee
i just say i really
am concerned
about the national trend
in disrespecting
law enforcement and removing
powers from them and
sends a it sends a bad message i think
it makes it harder for them to do their
job
and we need to
hire good people we need to train them
very well we need to supervise them well
but generally i i think we need to
accept that they have a vital role in
public safety so
uh i'll answer questions if there are
any
thank you representative
the representative is excused
the committee now calls lieutenant bill
bright new hampshire state police
good afternoon and thank you for hearing
my testimony committee for the record my
name is lieutenant bill bright of the
new hampshire state police i oversee the
narcotics investigations unit for
the new hampshire state police um my
concern a few of my concerns have
already been talked about uh
in the previous testimony
with this bill
um you know our concerns are that i mean
there's nothing in the bill that says
that it's
used to be used as a sole source um the
order of marijuana is very distinct and
can be used as a contributing factor in
many many cases
cases where there
are other
other factors that are going into the
establishment of probable cause
and this would add to those factors and
strengthen
a police officer's case so
for those reasons i have concerns about
about this bill so i'm willing to take
any any questions
representative welch
thank you for taking my question the the
scent of marijuana is that
having smoked it or is it the
weed itself
i have no
conception of exactly what we're talking
about here well i think that there's uh
you know oftentimes there's the the
order of fresh marijuana and the odor of
burnt marijuana
and as
has been mentioned they can at times
smell other things can smell the same
but when it's used as a contributing
factor along with
other factors whether that's other
evidence that can be seen or you know
heard or intelligence that's known
this could be
something that an officer can use to
establish probable cause and the way the
bill is written it doesn't appear that
it would allow for that
welch
how does this apply to the drugs
smelling the marijuana
uh that is a good question and i don't
know how this bill
would apply to that
but you are correct that a
a police canine
does detect
odors
representative calmly
thank you and thank you for taking the
question we heard from the prime sponsor
that the supreme court of the state has
weighed in on this subject indicating
that
um
dissent
is not
a means of determining probable cause so
would it stand to reason that all the
things you've just described as far as
the totality of a situation
you would need to build your probable
cause on factors other than the cent
so i'm not familiar with i haven't read
the supreme court decision so i'm i
don't know that but if that is the case
is that they've determined that it can't
be used as the sole
source then
then
the way this bill is written it doesn't
appear that it would
allow us to use that in
building a totality
case
representative green
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question i don't know when the
supreme court made a decision on this
but i know in the past
i've gone out with troop a on 95 and it
was their means of catching drug
traffickers
going to maine
being able to smell this would this
uh interrupt their work
well i i mean i don't know what the
circumstances were in the
cases that you were a witness to
but i mean the order of
the presence of marijuana is is
definitely a factor that a police
officer can use to either establish
probable cause or
um
you know ask for consent or things like
that
i'm not sure what the circumstances were
in in those cases
but if you were not allowed to use that
to build a case um yes i could
that could hinder some of those cases
thank you
representative roy you're recognized
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um as my colleague
brought up the the canine issue
is it true that canines are trained to
detect a wide variety of narcotics and
when a canine alerts on a vehicle or a
suitcase there's no way for the handler
to know
what exactly the substances he's hit on
until they've actually opened it is that
mike understanding correct yeah so i'm
not a i'm not a canine handler never
have been but yeah that is that is my
understanding is that they they can
detect a wide array of substances
depending on what they are they are
trained on and their indication to my
knowledge doesn't doesn't uh you're not
able to determine which substance they
are indicating on thank you
representative lange
thank you mr chair i just want to follow
that thread i am
i guess i'm
trying to understand from you with the
canine if i'm not mistaken is the center
for canine could be considered probable
cause based on um the fact that they're
an expert for lack of a better phrase
that that's how the court deems them
that a hit on on odor is
would be probable cause but by this law
that if this law to pass that would
definitely put that into jeopardy do you
do you think that that could be
absolutely be a factor there is uh
you know typically when a canine is used
there's been some reasonable suspicions
established um and that's used as a as
another factor i mean if that you know
if if marijuana this odor of marijuana
was taken out of that
depending on how the dog was trained
that may affect that
thank you the witness is excused thank
you
there any members of the public who wish
to testify that have not testified
already
please submit a paying card
seeing none and this time we will now
close the
public hearing on
house bill 1400.
it's probably better
i mean
the committee will be in recess to
2 15.
the 250 to 215.
hey
okay
seriously
i'm sure
thank you
wow
all 15.
uh
at this time we're now
we're now going to open the executive
session on house bill
1598 and this time the chair recognizes
representative wallace to make a motion
thank you mr chairman i move ought to
pass house bill 1598 and offer
yes briefly um this rather comprehensive
amendment
ensures that uh the privacy of new
hampshire citizens
that uh
go to a cannabis store will have their
identity protected
it's very comprehensive provides
the first 25 million dollars of any net
profit from this operation annually
going to hhs
uh for further expense excuse me further
monies to public safety operations
makes
driving under the influence unlawful
provides for that all cannabis sold in
the state shall be tested for purity and
make sure that there's no
contaminants
establishes banking
processes should financial institutions
not wish to
accept monies from cannabis operations
and provides penalties for people that
provide or make available cannabis to
individuals under the age of 21.
see see
representative morrison
you have a parliamentary inquiry
yes
are we talking about the bill itself or
the amendment that was passed out it's
the the question that is open right now
is is the amendment has been offered we
have to adopt the amendment then we can
argue okay so we have to talk about the
errors of the amendment yes thank you
this time
the amendment number is 2022-02078
this time the matter will now be put to
question if you are in sport of the
motion to adopt amendment number 2022-2
0-2-0-7-h
please say yes if you're opposed
police say nay
clerk may call they're all
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch
representative burt yes
representative rhodes
yes
representative greene
no
clerk votes yes representative testerman
representative lange
representative pratt
representative marston
thank you
no i'm sorry
yes
representative harriet gathright
representative schultz
sorry yes
representative wrong
yes
representative bourdain
representative perez
yes
representative newman
representative bolden yes
representative connolly yes
representative klein knight yes
representative bradley
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
18-3
by vote of 18-3 the amendment is adopted
i presume representative wallace wishes
to move to make a motion ought to pass
as amended
so moved
is that seconded by
secretary excuse me i have another
amendment
uh the members not hasn't been
recognized
did you recognize me
i will not
we're in the middle of a
motion of octopus amended has already
been made
and a member has been recognized for
that motion and i'm recognizing
representative klein knight to make
it's within the chair's discretion to
not
recognize someone to offer an amendment
you're not the only member of the
committee that has that complaint but
it's not a free zone
if
well
anyway
representative klein now you wish to
second the motion of ought to pass as
amended
are we going to have discussion
now we will have discussion
representative testament do you wish to
discuss the ought to pass as amended
no i
the ought to pass as amended is
only part of the bill
and and
i have a second amendment
yeah that will
you know
enhance the bill
it won't cancel it but it will enhance
it so
my problem is
that you're using essentially a
procedure
and a
a mechanism
to to basically
you know cancel this
and i understand the frustration you are
expressing my understanding and someone
anyone's free to correct me is that
there only can be one amendment
adopted and recommended by the committee
we cannot
actually adopt both
they could be merged
is a possibility but they i don't you
can't adopt one and then adopt the other
but we didn't even have the chance to
merge them
straight to the approval of the overall
bill and
respectfully it is within discretion of
the chair of the committee to recognize
which amendment to be introduced
i understand that you may not agree with
how that discretion was exercised that
message has been received and understood
i understand that but in in fairness to
the other members of the committee
that has happened to other other members
have voiced that same uh frustration on
other matters and other hearings
so
i disagreed then so never mind
does anyone else wish to
wish to speak to the
motion about the passes amended
representative lang you're recognized mr
chair i just want to i i know we've had
some conversations on this bill and as a
former police officer one of the things
that was most concerning to me is the
ability for law enforcement to be able
to enforce
dui whether it's drug driving or drunk
driving and i appreciate the fact that
this bill has money specif specifically
set aside to allow for enhanced training
of law enforcement officers to be able
to uh be able to enforce the laws and
our driving rules of the road so thank
you for the that inclusion in the
amendment
representative klein knight you're
recognized
thank you chair um i just want to for
the record state that this is a
completely bipartisan
uh piece of work
we met and worked very hard on
compromising
to
you know to be fair to everybody
we on the house floor passed a home
cultivation bill and this would not
interfere with that bill at all
so it's
um
a little bit of everything
for the state hopefully that one also
passes but
this is going to lower property taxes
it's going to fund public schools and
it's going to specifically go towards
juvenile behavioral health in the state
so i
would
appreciate your support thank you
representative perez
thank you
um i just want to add that i'm really
appreciate a pass on this bill it's
beyond time that we legalize cannabis
and and say new hunter i i believe that
uh this is going to help us to
bring some money song equity to the
state and um
that's all i want to say thank you for
passing this bill
representative bolden you recognized
i have a question this is an appropriate
time to ask a question right are you
making a parliamentary inquiry no i have
a question about the bill
of you i guess or anyone in the
committee who'd like to answer me you
may present i'm just curious what is the
impact on um
uh of this bill on
the
entities that currently legally
distribute medical cannabis in the state
are they impacted by this are they would
they be allowed to continue operating
thank you and the answer is yes that
they will be allowed to continue
continue to operate
and
they will not have any impact
and now there was a conscious effort
when this was drafted to not
have any impact on the medical
uh industry which is separate in in
fairness those and those are enterprises
or
businesses already operating so we when
we made sure not to do that at least
that was not the intent for us to do
that
you recognize again
representative boulder it's just i'm
sorry i think um
after asking that i realized what my
question really was was how does this
impact the
um
alternative treatment centers
that provide
services
currently
i believe that my same answer that they
would not be impacted by this that was
certainly not the intent to have any
impact on any existing business that's
in currently in operation
representative connolly thank you mr
chairman um
this house has tried for many years and
many a term to get
cannabis
legalization through and the outcome has
been the same
um every time this represents a new
approach
one that has not been tried
and one that hopefully will have a
different outcome so i'm looking forward
to voting for this
this time the matter will now be put to
question if you're in support of the
motion of ought to pass as amended
please say yay
if you are
opposed please say name the clerk will
not call the roll
vice chairman roy yes
representative welch
yes
representative burt
representative rhodes
yes
representative green
no clerk votes yes representative
testament no
representative lang
yes
representative pratt
no
representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright
representative schultz no
representative wrong yes
representative boardney yes
representative perez
yes
representative newman
representative bolden yes
representative conley yes
representative klein knight yes
representative bradley
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes mr chair i wanted to
make sure that
yes is
marked as my vote please i think i said
no in there
you did it maybe change the vote has not
been finalized
with a vote of 18 to four
the bill is adopted it can't be 18 4.
unless we got a new person
well
hang on
we'll get to the bottom of this
i stand corrected again 17 4.
life of 17
years four nades the ought to pass has
amended motion passes
would it be a majority report
you want me to write
i'll write it
would it be a minority report
representative testman will do the
minority report
at this time we will now close the
executive session on house bill 1598.
at this time we now open the public
hearing on house bill 1266 relative to
restrictions on enforcement of federal
immigration laws
the committee calls representative tony
pimanti
thank you mr chair and committee members
my name is representative tony piemonte
i represent district 4 sandown chester
and auburn
thank you for allowing me to introduce
house bill 1266 house bill 1266 is an
act relative to restrictions on
enforcement of federal immigration laws
i'm not against immigration i'm against
illegal immigration
that does not abide by the u.s concert
and new hampshire constitutions
my father immigrated to the united
states from italy
but he did did it the legal way
like so many others
it is the undocumented illegal
immigration that is jeopardizing our
safety and draining resources that
should go to immigrants
who legally come to the united states
all nations have borders we can't
sustain open floodgates
this bill house bill 1266 will ensure
that new hampshire
adheres to all federal immigration
laws at the local state and federal
level
i will ask for not to pass motion for
house bill 1266 i thank you and i will
not be taking any questions
the way the witness is excused
the committee calls eva castile
there good afternoon thank you for
listening to my testimony today
my name is eva castillo i live in
manchester
uh i have been in this country legally
also for 41 years but i happen to work
with immigration i'm an immigrant
advocate and nobody chooses to come to
this country illegally the system
precludes them from being here legally i
cannot spend tell you all the thousands
of dollars that i spent to adjust my
status
even though i was married to a u.s
citizen so this is just a side i'm here
to speak
um against this bill
part of my job is to build relationships
with the police
from
all latin american countries and for the
most part african countries our police
officers are crooked they're mean
they're corrupted and they're
criminals and that's what we grow
weary and scared of them in our own
countries i remember my mom always told
me stay away from the cops don't you
ever ask
for help from them
because if something does if the rubber
doesn't rob you the cub will
and this is what
our reality is when we come to this
country
we fear the police because that's all
we've learned i was a victim of a sex
crime in college
and i knew who had done it
and i was so afraid of the police that i
just swallowed it and i lived with it
because i was more fearful of the police
than i was of the rapist
when i came to new hampshire i started
building relationships with my
department in manchester
we first approached them
concerned about issues of profiling
and i built a relationship with them and
i learned to see
that what i have learned at home doesn't
apply here
the our police departments are an
honorable profession
and
that they are here to help us and to
serve us
so
i have worked with them for many many
years i still uh go all over the place
we have built all kinds of relationships
this bill would undo all those 20 some
years of work that we have done to
foster trust
in our police department
this bill is not going to help anything
it's not needed
this bill is going to preclude people
from trusting the police to come and
report crimes
this bill is going to make all our
communities unsafe this bill is going to
make our police departments prone to
civil lawsuits
there is no reason to have a bill first
of all our we do not have the resources
to do the feds jobs they have plenty of
money and they do their own thing so our
police department should not use the
resources that they need to keep our
community safe
persecuting people that are here
undocumented there's already rules in
the books
to
go after those
people that commit crimes that happen to
be undocumented immigrants
so this is only just gonna help people
do profiling
so i just
want you to think about it and
i urge you to vote this idea
representative klein knight
thank you chairman um thank you miss
castillo for your testimony today it was
very brave um and coming forward i
appreciate that
um
do undocumented people pay taxes
undocumented people pay taxes they do
not have the right to get a social
security number and the right to work
but if you do not work in this country
you do not eat
so the
irs has a tax id number and that's what
they use to claim their taxes and they
do pay their taxes
representative bolden
thank you for taking my question
you spoke about the
possibility that this legislation would
exacerbate relationships between the
public and police
is it the case
to your knowledge that
this would possibly discourage victims
of sex trafficking
from
going to police for fear of
being caught in
legal troubles
of course and and you know it has
happened before when we did not have
those open related and trusting
relationships where people did not want
to go to the police and it's still you
know a work in progress i have to work
on the immigrant communities to trust
the police but many times they're safer
they feel safer if they
tell me and i'll go with them to the
police departments but it's definitely
going to deter people from reporting
crime
follow
thank you for allowing a follow-up
so that makes me wonder if a police
department has a policy that um if
someone's brought to this country
illegally
um and they're being victimized being
sex trafficked
if the if the police government
department has a policy that they will
not um
prosecute that person for being in the
country illegally because they came here
through sex trafficking would this bill
require the police department to abandon
that policy require the police
department to prosecute a victim of sex
trafficking
there are special visas for victims of
sex trafficking so i don't think this
would affect that person but say
somebody happens to be driving without a
license
and they get stopped for an infraction
then the police department will be
mandated to call the police to cold eyes
on somebody that just happens to be or
if they just happen to encounter
somebody walking on the street that fits
the description of whatever somebody
that they're looking for and they decide
that they check their documentation and
find out they're undocumented then those
people will be affected i don't think it
would affect uh victims of domestic
violence per se because there are
special visas
for them
representative schultz
thank you mr chair
um i have two questions if that's okay
just one time i will recognize you for a
follow-up okay thank you
um
first regarding our current u.s
immigration
laws
are there limits to the amount of visas
that are available and do you feel well
this is actually part of the same first
question
that new hampshire's businesses need
more visas and are you know available
visas
oh yes there's limits of all kinds of
visas the work visas and there there's
different visa categories and there's
you know the main
way to immigrate to this country is
through family
relations but the countries that send
the most
people mexico philippines they only
qualify for like i haven't done this for
like 12 000 visas a year
so there's 19 million people waiting for
those
so it is really hard to to come into a
visa in fact
two days ago i got a an email from a
company up north that is desperate
looking for workers and ask me please
help me find people that are willing to
relocate
to the north country and i'll employ
them because we are really lacking
uh employ employees we we cannot find
somebody to to help us
representative schultz you recognize for
a follow-up thank you this is actually a
separate question
um
and this is looking at
information that was handed out before
we started talking about this bill so
you haven't heard the testimony or
probably seen the information that we
were handed
but
a national organization is here and
presented information about violent
criminals that are undocumented is there
a higher percentage of violent criminals
in the undocumented population
no and if that national
organization happens to be fair it is a
an organization that has been catalogued
by the southern poverty law center as a
hate
uh organization
and uh that's not that's not true in
fact undocumented immigrants commit far
lesser crimes
the
native uh born or people that have green
cards because they know what's at stake
also you know they come here to work
hard and that's all they want to do make
life better for their family just
like a lot of your ancestors did when
they first came to this country and the
difference is that probably
prior to 1924 there was no visa so all
that people needed to do was show up
and be counted my own family comes from
italy but they just happened to to stay
in latin america but if they had come
here that would have been the case too
thank you
representative testimony thank you thank
you for taking my question let me see if
i understand you
you said something earlier and i
mulled over
you said
something the effect of
anybody who wants to should be able to
come to this country
and work and have
a
documents and so on there should be no
limits to the people who come is there a
question
i mean did you say that
no that's not what i said at all
thank you for your testimony the witness
is excused thank you god bless you
we now call bruno de britto
good afternoon mr chair good afternoon
members of the community the community
my name is bruno de brito
and i am president of the new hampshire
brazilian council and i am also an
immigration attorney
i am here today
to speak about uh against
this legislation
contrary to what many believe
immigration is not a criminal matter
it's a civil offense
also
anybody that came here
before 1924
came here without a visa
so the same concept that these
individuals they are being called
illegals today
not necessarily that they were illegal
before
but simply they are being
made illegal today
but unfortunately you know people cannot
be considered illegal to be illegal
only drugs
contraband can be legal
no person shall be deemed illegal
we keep talking about uh you know like
illegal immigrants
it is a you know like an extreme
um
bad term to use
towards a human being
we should refer as
uh you know simply as you know people
and not illegals
also as my colleague eva
castillo you know i have mentioned
before
we have worked with law enforcement
for many many years to establish a
relationship between law enforcement and
the community because you know crimes do
happen in the community and not
necessarily they are committed by you
know immigrants
they are you know committed by everybody
and you know the rate of crime committed
by
immigrants are not necessarily
uh related to you know the increase of
immigrants who are undocumented you know
coming to the community there is a study
that i tried actually to to pull up
um that actually has
um that has been done in the national
metro area
that
um
that really breaks this link
uh you know about the premises that
the increase of crimes are related to
the increase of immigrants coming to the
community unfortunately i wasn't i
wasn't able to
um you know to to find that
you know when when i was called
but um but there is a study and i can
pull it up and i'll be more than happy
to share with you guys
uh and as she said you know like we have
established the relationships you know
like with police officers uh chiefs of
police uh the attorney general's office
uh you know to to work again to create
you know like a bridge between the
community and law enforcement and help
them to to solve crimes um
and you know like and unfortunately
these violent crimes as you know like as
i mentioned uh there is a memo by a
sheriff from from massachusetts that you
know only states one isolated case
that you know tries to to broaden what
really happens in the community so
immigrants you know they just you know
come here for the same reasons as you
know your ancestors you know came here
they come here you know to seek a better
life they come here so you know that
kids you know can get a better education
so one day they can become professionals
and you know fulfill you know like their
dreams and you know they don't you know
come here to oh yeah you know like we're
gonna go to the united states so we can
you know start robbing you know cvs so
that's you know that's not that
so
you know like one day you know these
kids you know their fruit of
you know the immigrants that are coming
here that many of you label as
illegals they're gonna be sitting where
you are right now so you know give them
a chance and stop labeling them as
illegals their people thank you
i'm open to any questions representative
lang you're recognized thank you sir
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
so i'm going to try and back up a little
bit in the conversational higher view of
this we're talking about policies
and establishing policies my question to
you is is it good public policy that the
state would allow a political
subdivision under it
to create a policy to ignore law and not
enforce law is that good public policy
so it's not uh so it's not that they're
not enforcing law and that's the beauty
of it so what we you know like have you
know like with the chiefs of police uh
you know like today state
is that
yes you are going to enforce the law if
you know there is a warrant you know
like uh in like on your name if you are
you know like an immigrant you know the
police you know like pull you over yes
you are going to be detained you are
going to be placed in removal
proceedings but if you are here
and you get pulled over because you know
like you didn't put your blinker on and
you got pulled over uh the police
officer comes to you uh asks you to
present your license and you're unable
to produce your driver's license so the
and you're only here you know to feed
your family to get in like a better life
you don't have any crimes you don't have
anything else
so
so in that case yes so the the person
will be sent to you know to the court
pay the fines that they have you know to
pay with the state
but they're not going to be asked you
know to
um you know they're they're not going to
call ice uh which is immigration customs
enforcement uh which is a different
jurisdiction
because the the job of you know the
local police is to enforce local laws
and not federal laws so we are trying to
keep
this separate that's all we're doing
follow up mr chair recognized for a
follow-up thank you
so again i'm trying to get because this
doesn't actually talk about an
individual right this is talking about
this bill as it exists is about
this state age about political
subdivisions towns cities police
departments establishing policies
that says we won't enforce
law
and and my question is is that good
public policy that we allow those
those organizations to establish overall
policy that would govern it govern
itself to say that we're not going to
enforce a law that was lawfully enacted
no it is indeed a good public policy
because as i mentioned before if it is
someone that hasn't committed a crime
okay so that it is not the job of the
state to enforce federal laws uh and
actually would be you know like deemed
unconstitutional uh as we have seen uh
you know like in the case of uh us via
arizona in 2012. okay
so it is uh you know the job of the
state
to enforce state laws it is the job of
the towing cities you know to enforce
local laws
and it is the job of the federal
government to enforce federal laws
and we should all keep them separately
we the state should not be burdened
because
we don't have that money uh you know to
be enforcing uh you know like federal
law and we don't get any you know like
federal money to enforce federal law
so
yes it is a good uh public policy
because these are families in the
communities a lot of families were torn
apart
uh you know so imagine like you're going
uh you know like out to uh you know to
your work
and you know like and when it's you know
like a lunch time you get a call you
know saying that your wife was detained
and you know like you're not you're not
gonna see your life you know for
probably in like another year unless
you're able to travel to another state
uh in locking detention and you know
your wife is placed in removal
proceedings so it's something that you
don't expect and these individuals every
day these are families again
uh you know the good people yeah let's
keep them here you know like criminals
yes the police officers they do enforce
the warrant that's part of uh you know
their agreement
representative schultz
thank you mr chair um
the
sponsor of this bill didn't take
questions but did mention the concept of
sanctuaries like sanctuary churches
sanctuary congregations sanctuary cities
in what way
has the sanctuary
uh aspect that i guess this bill is
trying to address
um been a benefit to our society
so honestly um
i i see it as um
you know like on you know like
i see it differently you know like how
can you knock this harm actually uh you
know to to this day to this day uh
we have no history
whatsoever
from uh you know like a uh
you know like an agency or anybody
trying to interfere
with item and customs enforcement we
don't have any history in the state to
to this date so that's how i see it
you're welcome
representative
perez thank you for taking my question
can you explain to me what the
difference is
when someone call
um
someone illegal alien
and and document a person
um yes so uh you know like an illegal
alien unfortunately is used uh you know
by uh you know like a circle a certain
group of individuals uh you know to to
look down uh you know like upon um
another and undocumented you know like
immigrants is more uh you know like
within you know the the boundaries you
know like of the law because the law you
know requires that you know someone you
know carries you know like a document
uh and then if that person doesn't carry
a document you know they are
undocumented
follow-up
you recognize for a follow-up thank you
uh do you believe that we have to
educate
our the people in our communities to
when they making a document to make sure
they don't use the illegal alien word
and the documents instead using the the
did the word
and don't document the person the member
would just suspend
we might try to keep the questions
jermaine to the bill
the prior question i thought was
acceptable
so
but would you remember i wish to ask a
different question not
is jermaine to the bill
mr chair where am i answering
the ques the question was was deemed
out of what the chair ruled it out of
order okay if i can just the chair would
inquire one question and thank you for
your testimony and taking my question
absolutely if a person enters the
country lawfully under our current
immigration laws
what is the i guess objection to then
enforcing our immigration laws while the
person's in the country
so in regards to placing them in removal
proceedings
i'm sorry i don't understand your
question
i'll re i'll rephrase it if a
person enters the united states of
america legally okay under our current
immigration laws if that person is now
in our country legally what is your the
objection to actually continuing to
enforce the immigration laws the same
laws that allow them to enter the
country
so i mean um yeah i'm i'm honestly
having a little bit difficulty
understanding i'm sorry
but essentially uh you know if the the
person enters you know the country you
know like with a visa or you know like
with you know like a green card uh you
know they're the same way that
uh the law is enforced
for uh documented individuals it is
enforced against uh
undocumented individuals and even if you
come here with a visa
you have to to follow certain
requirements
typically you know like a non-immigrant
visa when you come to this country you
have a certain amount of periods here in
this country and you're not allowed to
to get a green card uh you know through
the immigrant visa okay uh unless you
know certain you know exceptional
exceptional circumstances you know like
happen
and uh and then you're able to adjust
your status okay but that's a different
topic uh but if you violate you know the
conditions you know like of your visa
then um
you
you may
be deemed
um deportable
so
you know so pretty much it goes back to
essentially you become undocumented and
the majority of the individuals who are
here undocumented they actually they did
come with the visa
representative newman
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
when i look at this laura
my question is about how it potentially
could be implemented
and and the question is if you have
someone who is born here
and for some reason is
and is a legal citizen
and may have an accent
or or an appearance that someone may say
think that they are
could be illegal or not illegal
or anybody really
how does that person then prove it if in
fact they were born here would you have
to ask everybody if you couldn't if you
couldn't have any discretion as an
agency um
to
they would then have to say you have to
check every time you stop someone you
have to check and make sure that
representative newman
thank you
yeah so yeah and that's you know like
another you know like another thing uh
yeah so we wouldn't have to start asking
people uh you know for for citizenship
uh you know like statuses
um and you know there are there are a
lot of in like us citizens believe it or
not they're unable to prove that they
are you know like us citizens i have
come across you know like a few uh you
know in the past in like a couple of
years and actually they ended up you
know i can remove proceedings and you
know like and even veterans uh believe
it or not even veterans and you know i
can that's the the issue uh you know
like with you know one of the issues you
know like with uh you know this bill
and you know coming here you know
documented or you know like undocumented
um you know there are certain you know
uh very slim possibilities for these
individuals to actually become you know
like legalized um and actually there's a
report that you know uh you know that
that came uh came out recently um you
know that shared you know like what are
the most
uh immigrant uh populations in each
state
and you know i can guess what is the
biggest most populous
uh immigrant population in new hampshire
undocumented and uh undocumented and
documented
guess which one it is
yes you guys to correct it correctly
canadians
and i bet you know some of you might you
know might have thought mexicans but
it's actually canadians
any other questions
representative roy you're recognized for
a question thank you mr chair thank you
for taking my question i'm over here
front and center hello oh sorry that's
okay
um okay um it seems like we were getting
a little bit
far from this the law itself my question
to you is
how does somebody get an ice detainer
put on them
so so pretty much so that the only way
is is if ice comes uh you know in
contact with them
okay so either
if you know they they give you know
themselves up in like at the border
which you know is happening a lot
so
customers in border patrol they process
these individuals they are handled over
to
immigration and customs enforcement ice
and ice is the agency responsible to
begin the removal proceedings of these
individuals uh so that's one way another
way is if someone
um
if someone you know like reports you
know like an individual and you know the
individual is actually interest uh you
know like of ice
uh so then ice uh you know comes
uh in contact interact with them and and
then uh may place them in removal
proceedings or in some cases uh in order
of supervision and you know there are
other avenues that you know like ice
uses depending on the the person
so or if someone
documented or undocumented
they commit a serious crime
and and pretty much
and this crime is deportable uh then ice
comes in contact uh in like with them
and place them removal proceedings
you recognize for a follow-up thank you
so is it is it your position
that it's not okay or not good policy
for the local law enforcement to call
ice and inquire about that detainer if
in your own words some of the people may
have committed serious crimes so if they
have committed certain uh you know
serious crimes ice will definitely there
is no question you know like about that
that's uh you know like what i dressed
with the representative i'm sorry there
is no name um so that's what i dressed
you know like with uh you know like with
him so if they committed in like a
serious crime uh you know especially you
know domestic violence for for example
so you know like ice immediately uh you
know like if they're found you know
guilty you know like ice uh you know
definitely you know picks them up and
places them in removal proceedings there
is no question in like about that
it happens 100 of the time thank you
you're welcome
representative klein knight
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question
uh bruno uh
if this were to pass would it increase
racial profiling
um yeah absolutely uh you wouldn't just
uh do that
but you would uh you know deter you know
the the work that you know like we've
been doing especially with you know like
eva you know for years and years you
know to build relationships uh you know
with law enforcement and prevent uh you
know like people from actually you know
reporting reporting crimes as a matter
of fact one of the chiefs that uh we
have a relationship with uh you know he
he stated that he was investigated you
know like a crime that happened in the
neighborhood in his area um and they
went you know to knock on the door of
you know the family uh you know like and
everybody just pretended that you know
they were not home because they they
were afraid that you know
that the police was there to actually
you know like arrest them and place them
removal proceedings
thank you the witness is excused thank
you
we now call grace
representative newman your parliamentary
i just wonder where we are in that
process thank you
i have not expressed any limitation the
only time there's ever a limitation on
the questions is more due to time
constraints than
anything else
thank you for the clarification
and the committee calls grace
king
thank you thank you
so good afternoon everybody thank you so
much i'm very glad to be here to be able
to share my story with you um thank you
for taking my testimony my name is grace
candecke i'm the program coordinator
with the american friends service
committee i'm also a longtime new
hampshire uh native i guess i grew up
here i've been here since 1989.
so i just wanted to
first share a small story i grew up in
manchester um that's my hometown like i
said i've been here since i was two
years old and when i came to this
country i went to school here went to
webster elementary and when i was in
first or second grade i was walking on
hanover street
um no actually i apologize i was
shopping with my aunties
the witness will suspend we do have to
have members of the public stand on the
other side tape i do apologize for
interrupting
yes i just
thank you i do apologize and you may
continue sure thank you
so i will just say again my name is
grace kendake i'm here in opposition to
hb 1266 and i want to tell you a story
about when i was in first or second
grade
i grew up in manchester i've been in
this country since 1989 and i was
shopping with my aunties
up up where ames used to be on hanover
street and i lost them in the store i
couldn't find them and i was really
really scared so in my child mind the
best thing i thought could i could do
was to leave the store walk across the
parking lot get onto hanover street and
somehow make my way home by following
the lights of downtown that i could see
so i was walking and walking and walking
and walking
and i started to cry because i was dark
and i was scared and i didn't know where
my family was
a really really nice couple who was
taking an evening stroll
heard me
found me
asked me what was wrong took me to a
convenience store
and while i was there and they were
giving me some candy and everyone was
really really nice to me a manchester
police officer came over picked me up
and took me to the station
when i went over there after a little
while where all the officers were
treating me very kindly asking me where
i was from what my name was they were
finally able to find my aunts who were
able to come over and get me
now this is a pretty typical story i'm
sure for those of you who have kids
either your own or in your family and
what's notable about this particular
story is that at the time i was
undocumented i came into this country in
1989 on a visa so i came here as you say
technically legally i outstayed that
visa but at the time i did not know that
because i was a child i was undocumented
my mother was undocumented and many
members of my family were undocumented
if a bill like this passes or had passed
back then
it would have meant that if when i was
picked up by the police
they would have know they would have had
to report us
to immigration
and then we would have been picked up
and i would not be standing here with
you today i would not have gone to
school would not have graduated bought a
home married my husband and settled here
in new hampshire which is my home
so
for those who don't know
this bill does not do what it says that
it claims that it does i know that as
lawmakers one of the things that you
have to weigh the most is intent over
impact
and the impact of this bill is to
undermine what municipalities have many
municipalities including manchester in
fact manchester was the vanguard have
created in order to ensure that all
members of our communities feel safe
and feel that they can rely and trust
and go to the systems of support and
safety and care that we have set up
this bill in thinking about the impact
that it has on municipalities undermines
local control
it tells municipalities it punishes a
problem that is not in fact happening
our law enforcement have done an
incredible job attempting to connect
with the community respond to the
community
to be able to serve the communities that
they come from and a bill like this
undermines that it
undermines those relationships and it
goes against the very values that we
have as a state
this is a state that values being able
to look one another in the eye to be
able to know who your neighbors are to
be able to set forth the rules and
regulations that make the most sense for
the communities that we come from there
is no need for a bill like this and in
fact the intent as the bill sponsor the
gentleman representing the bill
clearly spoke of was about deterring
illegal immigration
illegal immigrants
immigration is a complex issue
this bill does not do that what it does
is it authorizes an entire thousands of
new hampshire residents including people
like myself folks who have already sat
here people you see very often and many
more that you don't see in these
hallowed halls who are working living
paying into the state who are acting as
our essential workers who are keeping
this this country this state running
especially now during this pandemic and
it is egregious and disappointing to sit
here and listen to something that could
pass that would undermine all of those
efforts that energy and that ability for
our municipalities to regulate support
and care for its citizens
thank you i'm happy to take questions
representative roy you're recognized
thank you thank you for taking my
question
um
is it your position then that no one
should be
deported from the united states who's
entered here without the property
documentation
that is an interesting take on what i
have just said
there's nothing it wasn't
so
like i said that is an interesting take
on what i've just said um that is not at
all what i'm saying so what i am
speaking to is the fact that immigration
is a very complex is a very complex
system and the problems that are found
in immigration are very complex and the
fact the reality is is that this country
deports millions of people every year
and the majority of those people
shouldn't be have been deported in the
first place and if we really want to
solve those issues and the real question
the question that we should be asking is
why are people who shouldn't be getting
deported getting deported
representative newman
you mentioned the impact of this
bill could one of the potential impacts
be
that
regular
united states citizens who were born
here or normalized here
could be profiled
and then would have to prove their
citizenship status and maybe have to get
somebody to get their birth certificate
out or whatever it is because as far as
i know that's all i have that proves my
citizenship
thank you for that question so i think
that's very interesting because it it
definitely does a bill like this
absolutely um does create a situation
where profiling ends up happening
because what you're saying is that
cities and municipalities who are
recognized who have worked with their
communities and their citizens to say
you know when these things happen when
lot civil law enforcement cooperates
with uh immigration enforcement in ways
that they don't need to is not
unconstitutional nor is it illegal they
choose not to go into um uh what is it
called what is the word i'm looking for
i speak multiple languages so i speak so
i think in multiple languages um
when they go into voluntary agreement
they're saying we do not want to go into
voluntary agreements because we know
we've done the work to understand based
on what we have researched and what
we've talked with with our citizens that
when these things happen profiling
happens and when profiling happens no
one is safe and the reality is is that
many immigrants live in mixed status
families my husband was born here
um sometimes you know if he has a part
like a deep tan he doesn't look what you
would think of as american sometimes in
the dead of winter he does so for for
many of us who come from mixed status
families we're setting up a situation
where a bill like this makes it so that
there is a sense of instability and and
not of being safe who knows if someone
in my family who will be profiled who
knows if what that it matters if i have
my i have to carry my papers with me
every time that i go into my car other
than my driver's license so the
implications of this bill is very very
disturbing
thank you
thank you for your testimony the jury
may inquire with the question and thank
you for taking my question
can you provide one example where a
person should not have been deported but
was
that was
so i'm not an immigration lawyer um what
i can say is i can provide an example of
a community member who is whose identity
i will keep very very private um who
is fighting for his life he's fighting
to stay here
he comes from a country where he is
absolutely would be taken he would be
killed the minute he steps set foot back
in his home country he is fighting to
ensure not only that he survives here
but that the family back home that he
has left behind the young children and
his wife
who are back home will be able to move
freely and not be constantly terrorized
as they have been since he set foot in
this country seeking asylum two years
ago now this man came with a cohort of
other african immigrants from the same
country or nearby
and almost all of them
were all were able to um enter the
country after a period of detention or
be able to adjust their statuses to to
receive asylum he was the only one and
the reason for that the difference
between him and them
was that he didn't know anybody in this
country so we were talking about a
complex immigration system that we're
asking the question why do people who
shouldn't get deported get deported it's
because of reasons like this
because of small
specific
very granular rules
that impact people in unbelievable ways
thank you for answering my question if i
can ask for the follow-up
so the immigration i mean that's that's
a federal law
issue that's going on i suppose my
question is
is if we were able to have any type of
immigration reform how would we do that
if we don't enforce
the immigration laws whether the current
laws or whatever we were to reform the
federal law too
so there's not enough time for me to
give a history lesson um but i think one
thing that's important to note is that
immigration law has changed drastically
in the last two to three decades so i'm
34 years old almost 35 years old and the
way that immigration law was set up when
i was two compared to the now being in
my mid-30s is very different and so what
we have is that we have set up our laws
exponentially administration after
administration to become even more
punitive to be to catch more people to
criminalize them to label them as
criminals to find reasons to put them in
detention deportation um and and close
them out from being able to come into
this country so we have already done
that we have done we have set up a
system that is focused almost entirely
on punishment detention and deportation
instead of what the system was
originally set up to do which is to
serve
which is to understand why people are
coming and then to sir and to figure out
what is the best way to process them
while maintaining their humanity so
again the real question that we should
be asking with the question that you've
asked chairman is that we how can we
build a system that uplifts that not
only lives up to the values that we have
as a country but serves the original
values of the ways that it was intended
when it was first built and and also
noting the fact as my colleague bruno
said before a certain point we didn't
have immigration system the way that we
do now and certainly if we've designed
it to be one way we can design it to be
another
thank you the witness is excused
thank you
committee now calls maggie forberty
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
maggie fogarty i'm the new hampshire
program director for the american
friends service committee and i'm here
today to speak on behalf of the new
hampshire immigrant rights network which
is a statewide coalition of
individuals organizations faith leaders
attorneys
working together to advocate for humane
immigration policies
certainly at the federal level which is
where our immigration policies primarily
are
but also at the state and municipal
level because policies are made there
which impact immigrant communities
and i have testimony to submit to you in
the interest of time i will just lift up
a few key points and then i'm happy to
take any questions
we are in strong opposition to hb 1266
we believe this bill is anathema to new
hampshire's principles of equity and
justice
it is unnecessary
confusing and vague
if passed this bill will cause
widespread confusion
and result in the violation of new
hampshire residents constitutional and
civil rights and will expose local and
state officials to liability
it also interferes with the independence
of our judiciary
as has been discussed immigration
jurisprudence is carried out exclusively
within the federal domain
mostly within the administrative civil
process
new hampshire has a full complement of
federal law enforcement agencies
operating within our borders
including immigration enforcement
divisions there is simply no need for
state laws or resources to be diverted
toward immigration enforcement or to
targeting immigrant communities
it is clear that the state and local
government authorities already have
obligations to comply with state and
federal laws
so this bill does nothing to
to
clarify that
the vagueness of this bill leaves it to
government officials to figure out how
such a law would apply in actuality
fear and anxiety about the presence of
immigrants in our communities has been
fanned by legislation like this
and contributes to a rise in hate and
injustice
national anti-immigrant organizations
such as the federation for american
immigration reform fair have been a
significant factor in crafting
anti-immigrant laws throughout the u.s
they were clearly involved in a very
similar bill last year h.b 266 and quite
possibly involved in the creation of
this very similar one
our legislature should not be influenced
by anti-immigrant sentiments
we should be enacting laws that protect
the welfare of all of our residents
hb 1266 is particularly pernicious
because it's designed to raise fear and
confusion within immigrant communities
its vagueness will contribute to
uneasiness as it's unknown how it would
affect all interactions between people
perceived to be immigrants and
government officials government programs
community organizations
immigrant families may refrain from
interactions with law enforcement or
participation in programs and activities
to which they are fully entitled for
fear of how this law is being
interpreted
if enacted hb 1266 would trigger the
risk of increased racial and ethnic
profiling animosity and distrust of
those perceived to be immigrants and it
doesn't take a lot of imagination to
know what kind of data is used to
perceive someone to be an immigrant
people of color will be targeted by this
bill
so for all of these reasons we urge you
to find this bill inexpedient to
legislate as a resident of dover a
community with a wonderful immigrant
community within that community our
local police have enacted a practice of
not seeking to determine the immigration
status of someone they encounter in
their normal course of business and it
has made our community stronger and more
welcoming thank you very much
representative roy
thank you thank you for taking my
question um
and and i i agree with you i think um
our country is made richer for
the for our immigration but i am
confused
because we also made richer because
we're a nation of laws
this bill as i read it i can't see where
it directs law enforcement to do
anything other than
not
thwart federal immigration
so i'm going to say something i want you
to tell me if i'm incorrect it
right now in a sanctuary city if someone
is arrested and they when they're put
into the system as everybody is no
matter their immigration status
if there's an ice detainer it pops up
ice detainer
this law would say that they do have to
notify ice that they have that person in
custody it doesn't say that they have to
go out and start asking immigration
status questions or stopping people
so
is that correct or am i reading it wrong
i think you're reading it generously
i think that there's that the language
in this bill is so vague and inclusive
that
that not doing
not acting as immigration enforcement
agents could be perceived as not
cooperating with federal immigration
laws so the issue pertaining to
detainers attorney clementos who's
coming after attorney debrito spoke to
to the fact that those are already
acknowledged among law enforcement
officers they have a duty of cooperation
but this bill is written in such a way
to capture all sorts of other
behaviors that would
easily be interpreted to be required
thank you
representative klein knight
um
thank you chair this is more of a point
of order
section
you're recognized for your point of
order thank you section 805 on public
order
um maureen maloney's testimony needs to
be stricken from the record it's
inappropriate and it it it just cites
that all immigrants are criminal aliens
and i urge that it be be removed
well
may you uh
you please read the rule again
section 805
chapter 74 of public order number four
it is within the discretion i can i'll
read the reading
apparently some other members would like
you to read it alone also thank you for
giving me the book
don't don't make me regret it
can you mind repeating the rule
yeah
um
i'm glad i didn't give you the gavel
section 805 maintaining order in
legislative bodies
um it is within the discretionary
capacity of a presiding officer of a
legislative body to insist upon the
orderly recognition of speakers and to
make quick judgments as to what method
to use to maintain order at emotionally
charged meetings
so your point of order is that the
written testimony submitted by a member
of the public
is
not income
violates
rule 805
well it it's it's inappropriate and it's
within our power to strike it
as it
so you're asking that you're destroy i'm
not going to strike any of the written
testimony
uh
submitted by any members of the public
i'll leave it to entrust the members of
the committee to
evaluate and take into consideration
that written testimony i also have not
read the written testimony yet so
i would have to do that in order i'm not
gonna
make that ruling right now
i have a question of the chair
that's that's the ruling of the chair i
will but while we're sitting here we'll
take a look at the testing i have
there's a you know you don't need to get
up
there's a copy right here the
my clerk sitting to my left just uh
pointed it out to me
mr chairman i was senator where you have
a parliamentary inquiry no i was
wondering how i could get one of those
books
you're handing them out i mean
just to clarify this is this is
borrowing
actually i will take up on the off that
written testimony you can pass it along
let me read the first one then we'll
worry about the second one
but we want to keep the
members of the public while we talk
amongst ourselves was keep the hearing
moving
mr chairman is this the appropriate time
for this no that's why i want to move on
thank you
seeing no further hands raised i want to
thank the witness for her testimony
thank you
the committee calls henry
clemenowitz
hopefully i didn't your name sir
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is henry clementowicz
i'm a senior staff attorney at the
american civil liberties union of new
hampshire
i'm here today testifying in lieu of our
legal director geolog who wishes that he
could be here with you today and sends
his regrets he had emailed you some
written remarks that i plan on
expounding upon
so
i want to start with what
let me start by saying that we're
testifying in opposition to this bill
uh and then move on to what i think are
a few drafting errors with the bill
um
so the first of which is that this bill
would prohibit
judicial officers from acting in a way
which restrict or discourage the
enforcement of federal immigration laws
and i think
this branch of government telling a
judicial officer what they can or can't
do raises serious separation of powers
concerns
um
in addition
this bill by acting upon any appointed
or elected official
could be construed as prohibiting
members of this body
from advocating in any particular way in
violation of the state constitution's
speech and debate clause
if this bill were to become law could
arguably
uh prohibit a future legislature from
moving to repeal this bill
because they would be elected officials
uh adopting a policy to restrict or
discourage the enforcement of federal
immigration laws and and obviously this
legislature can't bind future
legislatures and i think it would be
a violation of the speech and debate
clause for it to to criminalize or or
make illegal remarks of members of this
body or the other body
next i think hb 1266
could require municipalities to violate
the fourth and 14th amendments of the us
constitution as well as
part 1 article 19 of the new hampshire
constitution by potentially requiring
police departments to seize people
without probable cause
so an ice detainer is different from a
typical arrest warrant in that it's not
necessarily supported by a probable
cause nor is it reviewed and issued by a
neutral and detached magistrate so an
arrest warrant
in new hampshire has to be issued by a
judge
a member of the judicial branch whereas
an ice detainer
does not and so uh courts across the
across the country have found that
police departments seizing
um
people on the basis of immigration
detainers opera issued by ice have
violated
similar state constitutional provisions
because they're effectively making an
arrest without probable cause or a
neutral and detached magistrate's arrest
warrant
and i'd direct you to footnote 4 in our
written remarks
i'd also say
in response to a question from
representative lang to another witness
as to whether
it would be a good policy to permit
a subdivision of the state to enact its
own rules in terms of how it wants to
enforce the laws i would say to you
that currently police departments
and prosecutors offices
exercise prosecutorial discretion in all
manner of ways and for all manner of
reasons so
for example a police department a police
officer may see someone jaywalking
that's a violation of the law but they
may decide to issue someone a written
warning or a verbal warning rather than
a citation or an arrest and that's the
type of discretion that's
best left to local control
and so i'd refer you to a case that we
had
where we represented a man who was
seized by the exeter police department
in i think unusual circumstances so he
was
an undocumented person who was working
at a convenience store
when a woman in the convenience store
had reported that she had been
unwantedly kissed and the police
responded
and they they
figure out who the suspect is and they
go to try to talk to that person and he
doesn't speak english and so our client
who
was not the suspect but also worked at
the store offers to translate for the
exeter police department and he does
that and in fact enables the exeter
police department to assist their
investigation
after that the exeter police department
asks him what his immigration status is
and he answers truthfully that he's out
of status and is arrested
for my money that's a pretty good
example of
how
instituting a blanket policy that every
person who comes into contact with the
police has to answer questions about
their immigration status could
discourage
witnesses to crimes victims of crime
from cooperating with the police and
could make them feel less safe and i
would put to this committee that
whether and how to enforce those those
immigration laws that are really
primarily the subject of the federal
domain is best left to the locality that
knows those issues the best
i also wanted to
answer a couple questions that the chair
had asked of a prior speaker
mr chairman one of the questions you had
asked was how would a
lawful immigrant be negatively impacted
by this bill of past i think in addition
with respect to your testimony i don't
believe i asked the chair does not
recall asking that question
i mean you may you may speak as i may be
kind of hypothetical
paraphrasing i thought the question was
how could
um
a person
who who was
lawfully in this country
how could they be negatively impacted by
the enforcement of federal immigration
laws but
direct the question to you assistant
witness i ask that if some
what is the concern with
having a
system where a person lawfully enters
the united states of america but they're
not what what is the opposition or
objection to then enforcing those those
same laws that allow them to come
illegally in the first place but then
you're not allowed to enforce the other
immigration laws
thank you um and and i'd uh refer
members of the committee to put out two
of our written testimony which says that
according to isis own records between
fiscal year 2008 and 2012 it erroneously
issued 834 immigration detainers against
united states citizens
and 28 489
immigration detainers against lawful
permanent records uh residents so the
point is that that ice makes mistakes
and people who are lawfully in this
country can nonetheless be negatively
impacted by the enforcement of the
immigration laws
the other question
that the chair had asked was to point
him to
a person who has been deported who
shouldn't have been we represented a
person who was in removal proceedings
and had raised defenses to removal on
the basis of the convention against
torture and other
associated
laws which are basically defenses to
immigration and
after his case had been accepted for
review from the bia to the first circuit
the first circuit court of appeals had
issued a stay of his removal
and nonetheless the government deported
him in violation of that stay causing
him to spend
over six months in a salvador in prison
where
conditions are
sort of as you'd imagine and that led to
a round of briefing at the first circuit
as to whether the attorney general or
secretary of homeland security should be
held in contempt of court
in some i'd just like to say that
people who are out of status
may be victims of crimes they may be
witnesses to crimes
and allowing a local police department
to enact policies or procedures that
allow them to take into account the
complex realities of the communities
that they're sworn to protect
preserves
local control which is i think a
well-established new hampshire value
and inclusion to the community by
allowing people regardless of
immigration status to feel safe
reporting illegal acts that they say to
the police so that
concludes my testimony
and i'd be happy to take any questions
if there are any
representative rory
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
as an attorney
is it is it your opinion that it's good
policy to allow localities let's leave
immigration out of this is it is a good
policy to allow localities to decide
which
laws they will and which laws they will
not comply with from the federal
government
so i think what i would say is as an
attorney
immigration law is the exclusive domain
of the federal government and our system
of government in new hampshire is such
that generally
localities are free to use their own
resources the way that they best see fit
and i think in general allowing police
departments absent some overriding
concern
to
determine the best ways to police their
communities is good policy quick
follow-up please
um recognize for a follow-up thank you
mr chairman i'm referring specifically
to
to detainers uh i agree totally please
local police should not be enforcing
federal laws
but to the detainer question
should localities be able to instruct
their police departments
do not comply with federal detainers
um
because it's a federal law
should we be doing that in the same
veins should we also maybe perhaps say
ignore the second amendment laws from
the federal government we have our own
here in new hampshire
sure so
i guess the best way to answer that is
that courts across the state across the
country have found that local police
officers violate their state
constitutions by arresting someone on
the basis of an ice detainer because an
ice detainer is not an arrest warrant
issued based on probable cause and
issued by a neutral and detached
magistrate and so
in new hampshire a police officer is not
free to generally make an arrest
except in limited circumstances when
they have a warrant or when a felony is
committed in their presence and they
have probable cause to believe that
right um i think that a locality could
easily look at those cases that we cite
in footnote four of our written
testimony and determined that they may
be opening themselves up to liability
for violating someone's state
constitutional rights by using state
actors who are
not
authorized explicitly by federal law to
enforce these immigration detainers and
thus may be violating the state
constitutional rights of someone so i
guess i'd say
it is good policy to allow
police departments to make their own
judgment
and avoid violating state constitutional
rights of people
thank
you representative lange
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question so i want to go back to this
idea this concept of public policy and
and
ignoring laws
so i i guess
if the city of concord here decided to
pass and say
the city of concord police department
which is funded by the cities cannot
assist ice in any immigration laws and
then ice shows up the doorstep to the
local police department and says
we've done an investigation we have a we
want to go raid this house or this
location and concord pd says now i'm not
going to do that we can't i'm not
allowed to and puts those ins officers
at risk in a community they don't know
do you think that's good policy
so i think
number one that i don't i'm not aware of
any police department saying that we
would not provide that kind of courtesy
for an arrest warrant raid being taken
by federal partners i think what we're
talking about more specifically is
more likely is a town or police
department saying we have a policy of
just not asking people what their
immigration status is i think that is
good policy
follow
oh i apologize i was trying to determine
so again but but what this what this law
if enacted would do would prohibit a
city council from putting restrictions
on police departments from assisting
federal law enforcement officers right
it would it would it would
i wouldn't say it would require them but
the the law enforcement officers would
be free to act
um with encourage
in concert with
federal law enforcement agents absent
this law a city council could
potentially put in
a rule that would prohibit them from
from doing it
so i i think um
this this bill which is
one sentence long it's it's not entirely
clear to me that that's what this bill
does i think that a fair reading of this
bill is that any police department
saying
we're just not going you know we'll
honor detainers from
um
ice or you know will assist federal
partners as a rule when they ask us to
go on
i guess a raid with them
that may be covered but
also
if a police department were to say we're
just not going to
ask people who we interact with when
they're reporting crimes about their
immigration status
i think that arguably discourages the
enforcement of federal immigration laws
i think that the law as written is so
vague that a police department may not
feel that it could enact a policy saying
we're not going to ask victims of sex
trafficking their immigration status for
example
representative wrong thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
um
following some of your comments one of
the concerns i have that i want to ask
you about is
if this bill passes as it's been
submitted would it um
risk costly litigation on the part of
the state
it could or or probably more likely
local communities who are the ones who
would be facing section 1983 lawsuits
such as the ones that we brought in the
case uh that i mentioned before of the
gentleman in exeter who was arrested um
uh after he assisted the police
department in its investigation and so
yes i think it could okay thank you for
litigation
representative newman
thank you mr chair
do you agree that
the premise is that we must enforce all
laws and so i'm having a confusion
between this and forcing federal laws
and
just enforcing laws in general i mean i
don't think it would be good policy for
them to have a bill that said you
couldn't enforce speeding laws or some
other law is there a question coming
that's my question do you agree with
that
would that be good policy
because the police you know don't stop
everybody that goes over the speed limit
so i'm having a trouble with this
i guess what i'd say is that
it would be an impossibility for the
police to enforce every law all the time
and
probably not what any member of this
community of this committee would expect
the police to do in every circumstance
and
this bill if passed would take away that
discretion from
um
from the police departments and the
local control
that we value in new hampshire
thank you
representative conley
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question this is
an expansive um
bill and i read the
and i have questions coming but
when it says that um
there shall be no action
uh by you know person employee to
prohibit limit in any way restrict or
discourage the enforcement of federal
immigration immigration laws
would failing to ask
someone's status as you've noted is
common policy in many departments would
that violate this statute as you read it
i think it might i think that the
statute might also violate might also
prohibit for example the governor from
saying if he ever or she ever were to
choose
we think that the
federal government should prioritize xyz
immigration laws i think it's it's
beyond just
a local police department has to comply
with the request from ice to go on a
raid it's discouraging the enforcement
of federal immigration laws it's pretty
broad
if i may follow up that you recognize
thank you and you
sort of honed in on what i was getting
at with the discourage question that's
sort of an open-ended word
uh so is that then
if this were to pass would that then
force our departments to take certain
actions so that they did not violate
this
statute
i think it very well may
representative burt
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony
if i understand you're an attorney
yes sir yeah thank you
um
in this one sentence
four lines
i don't see where it says
that
if this passed the every police that
pulls over somebody
has to ask immigration like nazi germany
um and being an attorney i would think
you could answer
more
you know yes this is what the law is or
this isn't not it could or it may
you know i would like more of a direct
if you could where is it in these four
lines
that they have to stop people
of any color and say where is your what
is your immigration
status so
i guess i'd start globally by saying
that sometimes statutes are not clear
and need judicial resolution
and not being a judge i can't tell you
how necessarily a court would
definitively interpret the statute but
my reading is if a police department has
a policy
that says we are not going to ask
every single person who we stop their
immigration status or if they have a
policy that says we are not going to ask
victims of sex crimes their immigration
status
that discourages the enforcement of
immigration laws i think that's a fair
reading
of the statute
or restricts the enforcement of
immigration laws i think i mean i guess
my my answer is that restrict and
discourage are undefined in the statute
thank you
representative roy thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking another question um
i actually agree with some of this
vagueness
would what would the aclu's position be
on
this law if it just said
new hampshire
law enforcement
is prohibited from ignoring detainers on
someone who's taken into custody on a on
another crime
in other words not detainers that are
discovered like your client in a store
or anywhere else only if the person were
arrested on a local state crime by a
local law enforcement and they saw a
detainer in the system
they're prohibited from ignoring that
what would the position the aclu be on
that sure so if i could just start by
unfortunately caveating what i'm about
to say which is that i can't give you an
official position as to the aclu of new
hampshire without talking to all my
colleagues but i can tell you what i
think it it may be or sort of give some
rougher progress i won't hold you to it
sure thank you um and we'd be happy
i should say we'd be happy to
you know speak with you directly or work
on any particular language if that's
something you're interested in
one concern that we would have with
what you just suggested is if the
person's in custody but would otherwise
be released is their detention prolonged
as a result of
um the immigration detainer so for
example
um if a person is being released from
otherwise being released from valley
street jail
and that a thing pops up and it says
that there's an immigration detainer
and they call ice and ice comes over ice
is in manchester so it may be quick and
it may not
prolong their detention
but the same thing were to happen
um when a person is being released from
the jail in north haverhill new
hampshire and grafton county it may take
ice several hours to get there and so it
may be that the jail is otherwise
extending their detention by a matter of
hours in order to comply with the ice
detainer and so i think we would have
concerns with that because it would be
a detention not otherwise authorized by
state law and not based on
any sort of neutral and detached
magistrates finding a probable cause i i
hope that was clear enough
if it was if the chair would commit just
make a follow-up
so
i i understand so
under that theory though if anyone is
inconvenienced by the detainer
what good are these detainers if nobody
can act on them
well
i guess i would reject the premise of
your question that being detained in
jail is an inconvenience i think it's a
greater intrusion into someone's civil
liberties well if you were getting out
anyway and you had to stay an extra hour
i think that is a compensable damage
we agree you're an attorney but
regardless
i will say that i if if you have
language that you want us to take a look
at we we are always happy to do that
thank you
thank you for uh
uh testifying of the chairman choir with
the question
thank you for taking my question
i understood your testimony that it's
good policy for to allow police officers
to exercise
judgment and make judgment calls
what is there any thought on the on the
idea though that if you had the other
reverse policy where it was the standard
to not enforce any immigration laws at
all such as in dover would that
was your opinion opinion on a policy
like that
i'm not sure that i'm in a position to
announce an opinion on dover's police
policy which i haven't reviewed
if you haven't reviewed it that's a fair
answer thank you
representative connolly thank you mr
chairman um
we don't have law enforcement in the
room that i see so i'm not sure who best
to direct this question but i have heard
conflicting
uh
testimony about what actually happens if
somebody with a detainer
is
has an interaction with law enforcement
what would happen in this state i've
heard different things from different
witnesses and i'd love
an answer if you can provide that and i
just i don't see law enforcement to
direct that to i think it depends on the
department that
arrests them
some departments may check some may not
some may honor those some may not i i
think it probably is a case-by-case
determination is my guess
representative newman
thank you thank you
thank you for taking my question
um so
the police now have some discretion or
some limited discretion to
do what you just testified to
do you think that this bill would limit
that kind of discretion
yes
thank you
thank you thank you for your testimony
the witness is excused
committee now calls asthma elmwegie
finally
so uh hello committee um
representative abbas and committee my
name is asana el huni
and i am with rights and democracy new
hampshire
and i am also speaking as an immigrant
who understands many of the fears that
immigrants live with
as they are misunderstood minorities
often times in this country
including understanding that often times
because of stereotypes or
mischaracterizations of us we are seen
as a threat
as a muslim woman whose community often
gets labeled as violence i still face
interactions assumptions that i could be
violent and profiled because of my
identity
when i was a child i remember a woman
trying to reach out to my parents
basically was the landlord and she told
me that she would call police and tell
them that i was illegal and that we were
illegal
i was so confused
i did not understand what she meant
the strategy she employed of calling
police was intended to threaten us of
deportation
this very thing happens to many people
including victims of domestic violence
oftentimes they stay in abusive
situations because of fear that police
involvement could mean deportation so
actually this does affect people who
are in situations with domestic violence
i know there are laws to protect people
who are in domestic violence
cases to keep them in the country but
as someone who is an advocate for
domestic violence i am actually
certified in the state of new hampshire
and vermont
i can tell you that that process
includes getting a letter from the
police department or a judge so not all
women get that and so again not all
women go to the police department
because sometimes they won't give it to
them right
i did eventually become a citizen at the
age of 16 i need people to know that for
many immigrants there is not
a pathway to citizenship for them
and i do want to go back and just make
sure that
to be clear that a human being cannot be
illegal and so often times when we talk
about people that do not have
documentation we'll just call them
undocumented for those
who want to do the right thing and just
don't know what language to use we can
just say undocumented
because when we call people illegal we
are basically saying their humanity is
criminalized right so we're just saying
that their humanity is criminalized for
being human and that's just crazy
instead of the act of doing something
that is not legal
so there are several important points i
want to make today
one most undocumented immigrants have
actually come to the united states
legally
and found themselves undocumented
because of not being able to renew
documents because of language barriers
for example
also there are about 10 to 15 000
undocumented immigrants in the state of
new hampshire
undocumented immigrants boost our
economy
undocumented immigrants have contributed
14.3
million dollars in federal taxes and
guess what 6.1 million dollars in state
and local taxes and that is research
done by new american economy that i can
send to you
we could not continue to use immigrants
for their labor their contributions we
benefit off their backs but yet we
devalue their humanity it is time for us
to demonstrate our appreciation of the
labor and the sacrifices of immigrants
many of whom are essential workers and
have carried us through this pandemic
i'd like to share a story that an
undocumented immigrant has shared with
me
she came to the united states as a child
she did not know that she was
undocumented and she got older as is the
experience of many undocumented people
in the united states
she told me a little bit about her
struggles
she said when she goes into a car she
has to make sure everything is right if
it's dark outside she has to check her
front lights her rear lights because she
never knows if a police officer stops
her she is afraid that he will think
it's law
to call immigration enforcement and have
her deported because
you know they're taught they have to
follow the law and unfortunately like
some other people mentioned we're
talking about criminal law is the
federal policy and then we have civil
law
to be here undocumented is not a
criminal offense it is a civil offense
and that's what we're talking about so
when we're talking about also
detainers and this confusion about
detainers we have to understand that
detainers is not a legal warrant that
means there are some detainers that have
to do with a criminal offense somebody
committed a crime right and we should we
have to by law make sure we share that
information but when we're talking about
detainers for a civil offense that means
someone is just considered a criminal or
we just want to punish them simply
because they are undocumented and i
shared a story how some people no fault
of their own how they wound up in this
country that is ridiculous and that is
what we are addressing here
today
we are not saying going against federal
criminal law but what we are saying is
it is a civil offense not a criminal
offense to be here undocumented
and so
her story is just one of many i used to
live in the city of lebanon new
hampshire and we passed an ordinance to
ensure that police do not share
information with immigration customs
enforcement and again not all
information i'm talking about
information that has to do with a civil
offence just being here so that means if
a police officer stops someone and again
we talked about me being racially
profiled and other people brown and
black people and when police officers
stop them and they do not have
documentation they might call
immigration customs enforcement and this
is saying do not and this has helped our
community in lebanon it's helped
immigrants feel safer and so that is why
we are strongly opposed to this crazy
bill
representative klein knight i move we
itl this bill
second
we're there come on put it in your
hearts
i'll call i'm gonna call the
call the meeting to order
listen representative first of all the
members on the committee
only please only speak if you were
recognized to speak
you
that's one number two we're not in an
executive session
and i believe the member knows
knows that we're in a public hearing
there's members of the public
who are sitting in the audience that
haven't had an opportunity to testify
yet
and they've been waiting patiently i
believe we at least owe them those
members of the public the respect to let
them
speak whether in support or in
opposition to the bill
so i'm going to rule that out of order
and if even if we were in the executive
session you would still
need to be recognized to make that which
we're not so
that's that's right and i apologize to
the public and in the body
thank you representative knight
mr chair uh parliamentary inquiry
you i was gonna ask that the witness
wish to continue her testimony
i don't remember maybe i'll just say
yeah thank you um representative i will
just say like any one of you every
single one of you i should say every
single one of you
if you felt unsafe
wouldn't you take your family and leave
and i want us to think about that people
are in this country
not because they're trying to take
resources away and i talked about they
contribute here
they're fleeing violence
and oftentimes it's something that we've
done in other countries that has caused
people to flee where they are and to
seek safety so let's offer that humanity
that we should offer every single person
and welcome people
they are contributing members of our
society and until we fix our immigration
system and ensure a pathway to
citizenship everyone deserves safety
thank you for your testimony thank you
you representative are you ever you want
to be recognized for a question
i do thank you will you take the
question
yes who are you i'm way over here behind
the chair
you you um
you made a statement that
um being um undocumented is a civil
infraction
is it always a simple infraction no it
is not always a civil infraction and
what we're asking for is the fact that
when it is a civil fraction leave people
alone
that's what we're asking for immigrants
should be treated like every single
other person
thank you for your testimony
did you have a question for the witness
i'm sorry mr chair i still have that
question for you but i don't want to
step on
what is happening with our witness
especially since she's a constituent
of mine
i said if you don't have a question for
the witness the witness is excused you
may be recognized for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you mr chair and again i
apologize to the witness
for stepping on her testimony because
that is a faux pas she's my constituent
anyway um
i saved you
thank you i appreciate that i really do
genuine question because i don't know
the answer nothing
like up my sleeve or whatever
who calls executive sessions and how
is it only ever the chair or can anyone
else do that
and if we don't know the answer for sure
can we check we can speak we can i know
that's a complicated answer it could be
noticed it's noticed today that an
executive session may follow but we're
still in the public hearing so we
wouldn't end the public hearing early to
vote or make a recommendation to an
executive session to the public hearing
is concluded
okay but my question really is
uh whom among us i hope that's
can call executive session
the chair of the committee would have to
open the executive session no one else
can unless you're not here i assume
then then it would go to the vice chair
of the committee and then if the vice
chair and chair were not here would then
go to the ranking member of the majority
party okay thank you
thanks
we now call francisco it's like goulet
all right
uh that's the house my name is francisco
gular
uh
i'm coming from brazil
i live in united states for use on my
literacy story i
lived in united states for 33 years and
in merrimack new hampshire for 23 years
and uh my three
family
give to another station
for
four people for the army to working for
the afghanistan
and
my little story on
when i arrived united states in 1989
and
i got a visa for business and uh
now i have a
business in nashua give a job for five
people
and uh
and um
let me see
and uh just remember for the
the people in the this house
has
their hair white like me
because the my country brazil after
after uh war
civil war
opened the door for the american people
and they found and they planned for the
small small city in my country
called america americana
and they opened the door for america
it's now
i don't know why
this house
and vote for the about immigrant
immigrants is not people danger
immigrants people contribute for the
growth for the economy united states
and
that's the reason why we're here
and tell myself
why
for the house vote for the this bill
because immigrants
illegal or
illegal is no danger of people for
this
new hampshire because new hampshire and
the united states is made by immigrant
people for you know
that's my testimony for the
this house right now i'm
i'm
opposed for this bill
maybe my my english is not very well but
this is my testimony and i
free my finalizer i have a three kids
and
grow up two born here's one bar in
brazil internal state
18 months old
i'll always start university and grow up
here
and contribute for the united states
my family
the total for the united states about
fifty
five zero fifty people and they all paid
the bills all they all working hopefully
the bills build the tax and so no
have for the
united states of people working legal
here but
it's not
take nothing from the government or pay
for the care the money
and the working united states this is my
testimony i know i mean
opposed for this bill
that's all my testimony
thank you for your testimony if you
don't mind just please hand up the pink
card to one of the members
oh my apologies
does the member have any members
the witness is excused
if
if the members on the committee can do
their best with the electronic devices
i do have the discretion to have them
all turned off but
it is very distracting
uh 3d now calls sandra r pratt
so
i'm not a lawyer i'm not an expert on
anything
but i'm here because i am opposed to
this bill so i i will say before i give
my testimony
uh
i am sandra pratt i live in nashville
new hampshire for about 21 years
i came to this country with the
you know the legal status to study
english i wanted to continue my
education in brazil so i came here to
learn english english and go back and
finish my education there
but well i end up getting married end up
staying here i have two children i have
a family i have a lot of friends there
are documented not documented whatsoever
they are immigrants like me
i didn't have um
documentation problem because i got
married thanks to my husband
i work legally my whole life in this
country i am legally here speaking today
so
what i wanted to say is about a little
bit i know you're all tired i am tired
too but it's a big responsibility to sit
on a chair that you're sitting and i am
here representing a lot of people i'm
representing the individuals that i
serve from gateway's community services
individuals with a developmental
disability in my own brazilian community
from the state
so i just wanted to say that there are
so many other more important laws that
you should be
considering and worry about it
then this law that is just confusing to
me and i already say that i'm opposed to
that
laws
well i'm gonna talk about
microaggression first which is like um
today i watch a video and it explains a
lot so you can just um
it will be i'll be brief the mosquito
bite
every time people say where you're from
um
where is your accent from uh do you have
documents do you have drive-ins license
whatsoever it's like a little mosquito
that bites you when i start working here
legally at a pizza place
the lady the waitress would scream at me
and my boss would say
she's not there she can't hear she just
doesn't speak english
so microaggression is like that little
mosquito bite that you get every day
that a lot of people here are in this um
you know this position getting this
mosquito bite getting this micro
aggression like every day
um so my point is
people call me now thick skin because i
really don't care anymore if my english
is good enough
i just care about you know
i do have driving slice but do i do care
about people that don't so that's why
i'm here because i care about the people
that are
um not document or there are diverse
there are
whatever background
um to to be here for them so
i just think it's a big responsibility
to sit on the chair that you're sitting
and that you really should be worrying
about laws that will
encourage equity inclusion and diversity
that will include
and that will encourage that will
provide individuals with developmental
disabilities that i serve every day
with inclusion of hearing
vision and dental care
that's what i'm really concerned about
as well
and also the driver's license you know
every single person every individual
should be able to drive
if they pass on the right
right a written test
if they pay their fee if they know how
to drive the practical
test they should be able to drive so
there are other
bigger issues enemy immigration is very
um
it's very confusing it's a federal law
there's not you know a lot of smart
lawyers
get through the you know the laws and do
this and do that people
can change their status i don't
understand that my friends here are
lawyers they know better but it's so
complex and it's so confusing and it's
so not right if you can't have a green
card why can you have a great card and
be able to drive be able to work be able
to leave
so
you're tired i'm tired so i apologize if
i couldn't express myself well enough
but i'm opposed to this field thank you
and if you have any question i'll be
happy to answer
no question we're all ready to go home
we're not going anywhere
the committee now calls sherry rendall
good afternoon chairman abbas and other
distinguished members of the committee
thank you for allowing me to testify
today i'd also like to thank the bill's
sponsor representative tony pimanti and
also representative jeannine notter
who's here for support as well my name
as you heard is sherry rendall i am the
director
of state and local engagement at the
federation for american immigration
reform fair
fair strongly supports house bill 1266
we are a non-partis partisan nonprofit
organization of concerned individuals
who believe that our immigration laws
must be reformed to serve our nation's
interests we were founded in 1979 we
have three million members and
supporters nationwide
including 4 000 in the state of new
hampshire
and before i get started into my
testimony i want to say
we are a nation of laws we support that
and i also want to say that our
organization supports illegal
immigration
we are the most generous nation
for those who want to come to the united
states in fact right now i'm not sure if
we all know this we accept over 1
million 1 million
immigrants annually
so
we definitely believe
that
there should be a legal way into the
united states we do believe that
there are finite resources and and
we need to as a country determine the
best interest
now to talk about uh hb 1266 it will
prohibit jurisdictions from employing
dangerous policies that provide a safe
haven
or sanctuary in which illegal aliens can
live or work without fear of
apprehension from federal immigration
authorities
this is not about enforcing our laws
it's about prohibiting policies that
actually will not allow for the federal
immigration laws
to be enforced
sanctuary policies come in all shapes
and sizes
some are written some are not some are
enacted through local laws while others
masquerade as welcoming resolutions some
even appear as internal
policies for law enforcement agencies
however they generally bar
state or local officials including law
enforcement from asking lawfully
stopped or detained individuals about
their status
or
reporting or otherwise cooperating with
federal immigration officers
regardless of how they're enacted or
what form they take the common factor is
sanctuaries place a greater emphasis on
the welfare of illegal aliens than the
welfare and safety of citizens and legal
immigrants
hundreds of cities and municipalities
have declared themselves welcoming they
claim that they don't interfere with
federal law enforcement but that's
simply a fig leaf
welcoming or sanctuary cities actively
impede the enforcement of our federal
immigration laws and often attempt to
block free communication between state
and local officials and federal
immigration officials
since 2017 new hampshire in new
hampshire there's been a proliferation
of counties and cities including
cheshire county deerfield dublin
harrisville
lime manchester hanover and lebanon that
do not call themselves necessarily
sanctuary cities yet their their
practices make them function as such
enacting 1266 will ensure these
jurisdictions cannot prohibit or
restrict communication with immigration
officials
unfortunately
illegal aliens that reside in sanctuary
cities do not necessarily remain solely
within that locality in the sanctuary
city of lawrence massachusetts which is
only four miles from the new hampshire
state line
dozens were arrested in 2018 on federal
immigration
or i'm sorry on federal drug and
firearms and immigration charges
in addition the authority seized
10 kilos of fentanyl enough to kill
half the state of massachusetts
according to then u.s attorney andrew
lulling lawrence is a clearing house for
illegal drugs pouring into the state of
new hampshire
and maine
new hampshire has the third highest rate
of opioid related overdoses
overdose deaths in the country according
to the national institute of drug abuse
many of these are related to fentanyl
the majority which is manufactured in
both china and mexico and brought in the
states across our southern borders
according to john delena an associate
agent in charge of the new england
chart field division of drug enforcement
administration cartels like mexico
sinaloa are making decisions that are
going to affect what happens in new
hampshire
he says they have better research and
development than any fortune 500 company
furthermore
shielding illegal aliens necessarily
endangers innocent lives there are
roughly 3 million criminal aliens living
in the united states that is illegal
aliens with criminal records
in addition to their unlawful presence
in the country and nearly 1 million of
these have final orders of removal
these criminals should not be able to
continue to live in communities and
engage in further criminal activity
likewise the assumption that illegal
aliens commit crimes at lower rates than
american cities citizens is simply not
true in a recent study that fair did
of the state criminal alien assistance
program or scap it was found that
illegal aliens are more likely to be
incarcerated in state prisons and county
jails than u.s citizens and legal
immigrants
in fact the report found that in the
states examined illegal aliens are
incarcerated up to five and a half times
as frequently
as citizens and legal immigrants
additionally it found that the states
with higher incarceration rates of
illegal aliens are also the states
that boast the most number of sanctuary
jurisdictions
according to the office of inspector
general in fiscal year 2019 immigration
officers nationwide made 143
100 arrests of aliens charged with or
convicted of 489 thousand one hundred
crimes
these crimes included forty five
thousand 800 assaults
6 650 sex crimes and 1 923
killings
opponents of sanctuary policies
opponents of anti-sanctuary policies
justify shielding illegal aliens from
our immigration laws by saying it's
necessary for law enforcement to build
trust within the community
however state and local cooperation with
ice does not reduce the number of
non-citizens reporting crimes or coming
forward with testimony about being
criminalized
as mentioned besides the fact that
anonymous tips can be given there are
already a number of programs that
state and state local police can use to
encourage victim and witness cooperation
by granting lawful status to illegal
aliens who aid in the process
prosecution of criminals
they may qualify for u t s or vawa
non-immigrant visas which would allow
them to apply for permanent legal status
in the u.s
sanctuary policies actually prevent
illegal aliens of crime from taking
advantage of these programs
additionally according to a recent
report by the center for immigration
studies the data from the department of
justice national crime victimization
survey
shows that immigrant victimizations are
just as likely and in some cases more
likely to be reported to police than
crimes against nato reborn
they found that 62 percent of all
serious crimes against
against immigrant
were reported
compared to 53 percent against
um
native born americans
finally sanctuary policies tell
individuals that despite violating
federal laws law enforcement and other
government officials will ignore them
just because the regulation of
immigration is a federal issue doesn't
mean the state and local enforcement
agencies must overlook immigration
violations that harm their communities
there is a cost associated with
sanctuary cities which act as a magnet
for illegal immigration according to
fair's 2017 cost study new hampshire
spends 86.9 million dollars annually
and that takes into account the amount
of money they spend in taxes
hb 1266 is needed to clarify new
hampshire's public policy of cooperation
with federal immigration authorities and
for this reason fair supports the
legislation
thank you for your testimony
representative bolden
and mr chairman
i hope that this question is not out of
line and i'm only asking in general
genuine
uh curiosity i hope it's not outline
either
thanks and so that's why i'm practicing
with that is that i don't i don't have
any
mal intent
um but in the i i gather that you're new
to the building earlier i told you where
the bathroom was i think and i love your
shoes
and in in new hampshire state house
um lobbyists wear orange badges and you
don't have one on so i was just
wondering if you're a lobbyist
for the organization i'm representing
fair in its capacity as an organization
to state our opinion on legislation we
do have
we do have members in the in the state
but i'm not a registered lobbyist in new
hampshire
and
i would i would apologize i have i think
i only recall one witness actually
wearing
a orange badge it's my job to actually
enforce that i kind of over there's some
oversight of my end
so i i apologize for that but i can't go
back in time and fix that but i do
believe would be unfair now to strictly
enforce it on this one witness
but you're recognized
i i personally um don't know if you need
to be wearing an orange badge
um but if
that's the case would you consider
looking into it
okay representative
the questions are supposed to be asked
to ask or obtain information about the
bill or information relating to their
testimony
that
thank you
representative schultz
thank you mr chair since i mentioned
this earlier i wanted to give you the
opportunity to address this
so fair has been labeled a hate group by
the southern poverty law center since
for its ties to white supremacist groups
and attacks on non-white immigrants
how does it feel
uh being a part of a group known to be a
hatred
all right excuse me so i will address it
first of all
i'm asking starting not to answer
respond to the question i'm
getting the question out of order
can i rephrase it mr cool i just i with
the prior member that asked the question
the questions are related to the
substance
of the bill in the substance of the
testimony provided
by the witness
i am ruling that that is not related
to either the testimony provided or the
bill itself okay that's fair may i ask
you differently that's the rule
um i am a representative from concord
we're not too far from my district's
border
so as someone who doesn't live in new
hampshire do you feel you understand the
local state
laws and
local community laws and our high
property taxes
i'm going to deem that question on order
as well we
have consistently have had members of
the public who reside out of state
at least in this committee i don't want
to speak for every committee but it's
happened quite frequently so again if we
were going to
i'm not sure how to rephrase that since
this impacts our taxes i thought maybe
she had an expertise in some way to know
i'm deeming the question out of order as
well okay that is your right as chair
sorry mr chair
may i just mention something on
detainers
or is that out of order where testimony
is concluded but sorry
representative klein knight
oh representative harry gathering
recognize for a parliament parliamentary
inquiry well you can tell me if that's
it okay
we've sat here all day and we've
listened this evening listening to
testimony about that terminology a
little illegal alien
and the fact that you allow people and
that was part of what
we were talking about here
you have the right not to allow that
type of testimony that's so offensive to
many people in this room
and and and i'm very serious about this
because enough is enough
wait
hear me out no please hear me out okay
it's the same way that we're sitting in
this room and someone wants to use the
n-word okay it's just as offensive so
i'm just saying that you know we have to
do better than this that we represent
the people all the people
as a committee before i respond to that
i just asked that the members of the i'm
going to call the room to order again
i'm asking
the members in the public to not be
yelling stuff out it makes it very
difficult for the community to do its
do its business here
to the extent
to the extent that that was a point of
order it would it should be early early
but i'll address it
i understand that some some people may
find the term offensive
illegal alien however in under federal
law that that term is constantly listed
as a legal term i'm not saying that i
agree that they shouldn't change it but
that's on that is something that is
listed under several laws so when
someone does make that
i'm i'm not i'm not the one that wrote
the federal laws i'm just explaining i'm
just explaining that when people do use
it
in this context
it is still a legal classification i'm
not saying that they shouldn't change
the legal classification
my point is it's hard to i wouldn't rule
someone out of order in for using in
that context
you have the power in this room to make
that type of decision can say we
the terminology is not um welcome today
or whatever
whatever you need to say
so that it would not be offensive to
everyone sitting in this room
that's all i'm saying the best way to
address that would be to contact our
federal delegation and have them sponsor
legislation at the federal level to
remove that language from the federal
laws because the people who do use it i
understand that what people do find it
offensive but when it's written in law
that's where some of the confusion comes
from
so i i appreciate i appreciate the point
made
by the rep mr chairman can i make a
point of order please
representative burt you were recognized
for your point of order please state it
mr chairman
i know i have questions of
the person given the testimony at this
point so are we going to do point of
orders all night or can we get back to
the business and do point of orders
after everybody wants to leave
i
respectfully i'm not sure that's a point
of order correct probably so your point
of order is also out of order thank you
it's a parliamentary inquiry it sounds
like and
a point of order has to be addressed
when raised and i could actually
find a point of void to be dilatory
which i'm very i'm considering it i
don't find
the
parliamentary inquiry slash point
avoided by representing harry catherine
to be dilatory
you know mr chairman i just see a lot of
hands up and the witness
you know is sitting patiently uh waiting
for my question and i'm sure anybody
else's question and
you know it's just rude in my eyes that
we can handle this internal stuff after
the hearing
do any members of the committee have any
questions for the witness
i have a question of the chair
you
before that do we have any questions for
the witness
representative wrong you're recognized
as a witness of the question yeah right
that's all right thanks a question to
the witness i'm just thanking you for
allowing me to speak and thank you for
taking my question you cited a lot of
data
on the national level but i was
wondering if your organization had
data that's new hampshire specific
um and i noted just from the national
numbers you gave me do you have anything
specific to new hampshire on
uh the number of taxpayers
who
or taxes spent in new hampshire
or paid by
i don't know you know the people
jobs they hold how many jobs are held in
new hampshire
and the percent of arrests in new
hampshire
from
undocumented immigrants
thank you for that question um the
number of arrests is very hard data to
get a hold of
it's not always reported so it is
difficult to get a hold of with respect
to
the cost to new hampshire i did cite
that it was 86.9 million dollars is what
it cost after taxes
so it's a 132 billion
nationwide and then 40 uh i'm sorry
86.9 million
in new hampshire and that's after you
account for all the taxes that they do
pay
okay follow-up
mr chair you recognize for a follow-up
um do you know um
one of the things i include in my
question but i'm sorry it was it was
long is do you know how many jobs are
held in new hampshire
um
by
by illegal yeah well i i'll say
undocumented i'll be respectful and just
say undocumented immigrants excuse me
it's not we don't need to imply anything
that's
that issue has been addressed already
okay thank you i just didn't want to use
the term that that people receive you
can use the term undocumented i use that
term that's
okay i understand okay thank you so do
you know how many jobs in new hampshire
are held by undocumented immigrants so i
do not have that statistic
reality says there should be no jobs
held by those here illegally according
to federal law
okay thank you
representative newman you were
recognized to ask the witness a question
thank you mr chair that's exactly what i
intended to do
you mentioned in your testimony earlier
you gave a list of cities in
new hampshire
that you said i believe
act like
uh uh
no i mean i've lost the term the
sanctuary cities
uh but are not
i'm just wondering if the data that you
used to
make that statement
was based on an examination of written
policies that they have or could some of
those policies just have been verbal
policies like we don't have a lot of
money so your priority is go to the most
serious things and and kind of leave the
immigration things like that were they
written or verbality no
thank you for that question they were
written policies um
mostly
and they were based on the fact that we
had looked at
actually had to research into the states
and look at what the statements were
so while they don't call themselves
sanctuary in the in the in the term they
are acting like sanctuary cities and
they have policies written that have uh
interfered with
um or prohibited communication free
communication
um on
immigration issues
follow up follow up mr chair
representative newman you were
recognized for a follow-up question
thank you
um
is it your opinion that the way this
this bill is written where it says
prohibited from acting in any way that
would discourage
uh enforcement of federal immigration
laws
do you believe that this law would then
prohibit
cities that don't have written policies
but they say the same kind of thing that
if we don't have the money and and don't
do the most important laws now and don't
do the immigration stuff
that that kind of verbal
non-written documentation
would also prohibit those cities from
being able to
tell their police that that is their
policy if it's from the council
or or local governments basically
verbally telling the law enforcement
that they can't enforce or communicate
yes that's an issue because you are
prohibiting free communication and
cooperation
with
federal immigration officials and in
fact
state and local
governments and localities law
enforcement cooperate with federal
officials on
many many levels including
bureau of alcohol tobacco and firearms
including marshals there are many times
when there should be cooperation with
our federal partners on the local and
state level and so we want to ensure
that there are policies in place
place that prohibit
a locality from
not being able to cooperate or
communicate
representative klein knight you
recognized
thank you chair
uh you mentioned a lot of money um being
spent
and um
so
that's very good to know and then you
said uh one million people
um
what was you said one million people
have final orders of removal
yeah how many undocumented individuals
did the states let in last year and of
that number how many were criminals
you're asking how many i'm sorry for
clarification purposes you're asking me
how many um
people
new hampshire led in illegally
how many undocumented people did the
because you're national right you can
just tell us uh the in the united states
if if you have that data how many
undocumented
did we let in into the united states of
america last year and of that number how
many were actual criminals because this
is all based off of their criminals
right
what we're saying is these are the
people that we already know have final
orders they've gone through the process
and they have final orders of removal as
far as those who have been
admitted illegally i don't believe that
the federal government admits anyone
illegally into our country but there are
numbers that anticipate the numbers of
people who are here illegally and i know
last fiscal fiscal year
it was on track to end with 200 or i'm
sorry 2 million people being here
illegally
out of those
i can't tell you how many have criminal
records
um i'm not sure that ice or
cbp even have the numbers of those
at this point who have criminal records
from those being admitted
who have entered our country illegally
if that makes sense
representative knight you recognize for
a follow-up question thank you chair um
so we don't have an accurate number of
how many were criminals but we need a
law
to prevent these criminals from entering
is there a question there is that true
you you feel like we need a law but you
don't even have the data to prove that
we need a law
i'm not sure that's a question
i i'm just trying to keep the committee
in order without letting it get out of
hand so i'm gonna
not give much leeway for the rest of the
day
representative burt you were recognized
thank you mr chair
i was going to start in state but ever
since we're talking about
the nation um i did want to mention that
too
what will this bill do
with the current administration
which i believe is following what
president obama and president trump are
pretty much doing you know the current
administration is following their mostly
their footsteps
um with detaining people in jail and
stuff like
like that when they come across the
border illegally
what will this bill do
with the current administration what
they're doing
so uh with the current administration
the current administration hasn't been
um
enforcing many of our immigration laws
with respect to this bill it will
enforce the rule of law and make sure
that
we are not acting as a magnet for
illegal immigration here in the state it
will ensure that there is opportunity to
communicate and cooperate with our
federal officials ultimately it is the
federal officials determination on
whether they pursue someone who is here
illegally it is their domain not the
state's domain but to be able to
keep the chain the lines of
communication open and not prohibit that
communication which some localities have
uh
done is what's important all right and a
follow-up mr chairman
thank you mr chairman
in this four line bill one sentence
basically
i heard a lot of talk
that
it's going to tell
local police
and state police if they pull somebody
over they can question their immigration
can you tell me where that is in here
this bill from my reading of the bill
will give them the discretion if they
choose to ask about immigration status
or it will
allow them not to it's their discretion
from what i can see the operative word
are implementing policies
so if an individual is stopping someone
on an individual basis they have the
opportunity to use their discretion
that's what you want your law
enforcement to be able to do and not
have a blanket prohibition
that they can't and just one short
follow-up to that same question
you may be recognized for a follow-up
thank you mr chairman um
do they currently have that right
in most places in new hampshire they do
but in the localities that i mentioned
they don't all right thank you
thank you the witness is excused thank
you
are there any members of the public who
are present who wish to testify that
have not testified already
at this time we will now close the
public hearing on
house bill 1266.
uh
representative lane give me a mind
approaching
thank you
this
is you
i want two minutes of personal approach
at this time i'm going to call the
committee room to order
at this time
we were going to open the executive
session on house bill
1388 relative to the unsolicited
disclosure of an intimate image
representative collin you're recognized
thank you mr chairman i'd move out to
pass on hb 1388
second
that motion has been seconded by
representative klein knight
do you wish to speak to the
your motion briefly mr chairman uh we
have heard this bill now twice
uh we passed it last year
and i believe we ought to pass it again
thank you
representative perez you're recognized
thank you mr chair for giving me the
opportunity i would like to say that i i
want to see this bill pass
someone who um
in
the end of 2020
when i was elected as a
state representative
i was looking for
a job that i can be
flexible with me being a star
representative
i went to a local business that i
previously worked when i was here
french
in the country
the person
who's a manager that that business asked
me if i was looking for a job and i say
yes
that night
when
i was home with my husband i get a text
from this person
let me explain to you first of all
i'm a survivor from sexual assault
from the age of 5 until 15 years old
before i marry my
abusive husband ex-husband
when that
manager from this establishment
sent me a nude picture
of himself
that
brought back flashback
from my sexual assault when i was little
it was so hard for me to show my husband
what was happening at that moment
but i was
i talked to some of my friends
and my friends told me that i should be
open to my husband
and show him exactly what happened
my husband told me that i have the right
to put legal
consequences to this manager
as a state representative i was
embarrassed
to evolve into the police and show them
what this manager sent me a new picture
of his powers
and after that he sent me a picture of
him drinking tequila shots
i felt that i was sexually soul again
so that's why i support
to pass this bill because
victims like myself we need to be
protected for this not to happen again
it is incredibly painful for someone who
already
have ptsd from being a victim of sexual
assault and you feel like you've been
abused again by a picture sent
by someone who helped it
i'm sorry
he called me the next day
he sent me a text
asking me if i was still willing to take
the job and work for him
hot in the world i was going to be able
to work for someone who already sent me
a new picture of his parts
and then make me feel like already
was getting sexual assault again
thank you so much
representative rhodes you are recognized
thank you mr chairman i just would like
to
point out to those in the room that
don't know this but this bill actually
did pass
not only did it pass our committee it
passed the house floor and it also
passed
the senate
the other body
and went to committee of conference and
a lot of the questions that were that
were brought up earlier today whenever
we reheard the bill by the
representative that resubmitted it um
were actually
addressed in the committee of conference
that the
that the attorney i believe spoke to
so i i just wanted to um
to remind people of that
thank you representative and for the
members who weren't president for the
committee of conference we only had in
the bill last term the
prime spawn sponsor the representative
actually
caught a drafting error that
saved us all from an embarrassment
because it may have there was some talk
of what maybe that would have legalized
or made it a violation to send
lewd images of a minor which is not the
intent of the
sponsor so it was a very good catch by
the representative filed this
and uh who's not even a member of the
committee but was on the committee of
conference with us so again
and she doesn't have a legal background
so you have it was just an impressive
catch so we were all thankful that she
did that then refiled
um the reason why this language was not
accepted at that time was it really was
the vetting process given what almost
just happened
so it's now gone through that process
and
the encouragement is that you know
people regularly interact in
whether it's affection or intimate
situations that's
it's consensual
so there's no reason why that shouldn't
extend to
digital contacts
at some point it needs to be if
someone's going to continue to do that
that
needs to be some remedy for a person the
receiving end of that so
i'll be supporting the
motion about to pass and i was happy to
co-sponsor this legislation
just
see no further hands raised the matter
will now be put to question
if you support the motion of ought to
ought to pass please say yay
if you are opposed please say
please say nay the clerk will not call
the roll
vice chairman roy yes
representative welch yes representative
burt
representative rhodes
yes
representative greene yes
clerk votes yes representative testament
not voting representative lang
yes representative pratt yes
representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright
representative schultz
yes
representative wrong
representative bordenay
yes
representative perez
representative newman
yes representative bolden
yes
representative conley
representative klein knight yes
representative bradley
chairman abbas
chair votes yes 20 yays zero nays one
not voting
majority report
at this time we will now close the
executive session on house bill
1388.
at this time we are now going to adjourn
the
criminal justice public safety committee
about
anything